got 52
[Music]
on
attend right you can begin
representative major oh thank
you
okay as chair of the house Ways and
Means Committee I find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of covid-19
pandemic in accordance with house rule
67 and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to the executive
order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a joint Ways and
Means
committee economic
briefing please note there is no
physical location for members for the of
the public to observe and listen
contemporarily to this meeting however
in accordance with the emergency order I
am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
have the ability to communicate cont
temporarly during this meeting through
the zoom electronic meeting platform and
the public has access to contemporarily
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available to
the house Clerk and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS
l.st n. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and rescheduled I want
to introduce the staff that are on the
meeting assisting us Jennifer four wave
Jennifer and Christopher Shay from the
LBA Christopher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states the presence
please also State whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to no law so uh representative
barstein if you would as clerk call the
rooll so thank you Mr chair uh let's
start with our friends in the Senate
Senator Gary
Daniels Senator Gary
Daniels Senator Bob
GAA Senator G is here alone in my home
in MO in New Hampshire Senator
Hennessy Senator
Rosenwald hi Cindy rosenal from Nashua
I'm in my home alone
Senator delandro hi Senator Lisandro I'm
uh at my home in Manchester and I'm
alone thank you and let's move to the
house representative
abrami alone in stratum in my home
representative
Griffin representative Griffin I see her
on the
call she may have forgotten how to sign
in representative Griffin if you press
star six that will unmute you so you can
speak with the
committee we will come back to
representative Griffin once I see her
unmuted representative oh there you are
good morning
Mary representative
oy yeah I'm here oh terrific
representative
obber representative
duet representative du
set representative burin is your Clerk
and I'm here in Nottingham New Hampshire
in my home office by myself
representative
Elliott representative
Elliott representative Jan
janigian very close hard G janigian
janigian thank you um I here in Salem
New Hampshire with my wife and daughter
somewhere in the house very good
representative
Nunes good morning I'm here and I'm home
alone in Pelham New Hampshire
representative
Baxter representative
Baxter representative spillsbury
representative spillsbury I see you on
the call star six if you're on the
phone Walter are you
there representative tutor here in
Northwood in the Sol alone
representative
Aly unmute
yourself representative only me un your
muted sorry uh home alone in my uh in
Lebanon and
representative just showed up okay thank
you representative
a yeah this is uh representative Ames
and Jeffrey alone in my home office
representative
Southworth see if I'm unmuted
representative Southworth I'm home alone
in do representative
Malloy representative
shamberg uh representative shamberg here
in wilmet and I'm home alone
representative
Tucker representative Tucker I'm home
alone in Randolph New Hampshire
representative
garlo uh representative garlo in
Swansea and I'm home alone thank you
representative
lman it's representative lman and
Hampton um with my two
kids representative
gorg here in Lee in my home office by
myself representative hackin Phillips
good morning representative hacken
Phillips present here and my office in
conquered alone representative Murphy
good morning repres resentative Murphy
here in Handover with my wife and
daughter elsewhere in the home
representative
major good morning I'm here in plasto
and my wife is in the house with me
representative
ducet good morning representative ducet
on my mobile
device awesome I'm showing uh there's 22
of us here and there are six absent
representative bin I'm sorry for
interrupting but um I just noticed that
Senator Daniels was in the attendee side
and I just promoted him terrific Senator
Daniels are you
here Senator Daniels hit on mute and
tell me you're here say good morning H
good morning yeah it took it took a long
time getting in thank you I'm here in
Milford and I'm alone awesome thank
you
okay we have 23 here five
absent all right we'll get started we
have a very busy two
days of
U listening to different speakers that
affect the economy and which will have
an effect on our
revenues and we're here to ultimately
come up with Revenue projections to to
give to
our friends that are in this the finance
committee so we can know they'll know
what the limit is for spending for the
budget we're going to start off
today with Michael K from the LBA
Michael K currently serves as the
legislative budget assistant of the
State of New Hampshire Michael has
served as the
LBA
since September of 2015
has been employed by the office since
1999 serving in multiple capacities
including Deputy LBA senior budget
officer and budget officer before coming
to New Hampshire Michael was employed by
the Massachusetts House of
Representative as a budget analyst in
the house Ways and Means Committee which
is their
Appropriations Michael HS and Masters in
public administration from selfic
University and a bachelor's degree from
merac
college Michael you're
on good morning can you all hear me and
before you start Michael had provided us
of a two page handout so I'm sure he'll
be referring to
that yes good morning uh for the record
my name is Michael Kane I'm the
legislative budget assistant I am here
in my home in Warner New Hampshire um I
will actually turn and share my screen
in a moment which will go over the
document uh which was emailed uh and
also posted on the website uh quickly I
was going to go over our role the
legislative budget assistant has two
divisions the budget Division and the
audit division the house Ways and Means
Committee Senate Ways and Means
Committee and then the House and Senate
Finance committees uh really work with
our budget division which has a deputy
LBA cret which will be assisting the
ways and means and capital budget
Committees of both the house and the
Senate as well as a senior budget
officer Mike Hoffman and then budget
analysts uh Nancy lavenus Kevin Ripple
and Mickey landeron who assist the
finance committee as they develop the
budget um as you know the governor's
budget is released on February 15th uh
at that point the House and Senate
Finance committees begin their budget
process uh but as far as an official
kickoff of the legislative budget
session um typically these joint
economic briefings are the first step in
developing a balanced budget for the
next bium the next bium being the 22 and
23 uh fiscal year 22 and 23 uh binal
budget um typically after the join
economic briefings the house Ways and
Means Committee since the house does
have first possession of the budget the
house way means Community will develop
Revenue estimates after meeting with
various e economists various agency
staff and they provide a their best
estimate of general and education trust
fund fish and game and Highway fund
Revenue to the house finance committee
as represented major stated house
finance then uses that as a baseline as
they develop a budget the state uh
pursuant to statute is required to pass
a balanced budget for the bayum so the
the revenue estimates are very important
um and a very important piece of uh the
house finance development of the budget
there also constant interaction between
crishet and our office and myself uh as
well as the chairs of the ways Means
Committee and the chair of the finance
committee uh to go over uh what you're
seeing on the revenue side at Ways and
Means so that the house can adjust their
Appropriations accordingly um I know you
have Dr coming at 9:30 I'm going to
share my screen right now and I'm going
to I'll just ask in one
moment so you should be able to to see
uh our website for the office of
legislative budget assistant can you see
that okay and I'd like to take you
through kind of how to get to the
document you are today first this is a
good resource we believe uh to kind of
keep up to date on the status of the
budget process as we go through um in
the budget division you can see we have
a couple dropdowns one of the dropdowns
being budget and revenue documents and
we have various operating budgets all
the way back to the 989 time frame as
well as an operating capital budget
document page uh back to 2002
2011 uh which will show you uh basically
U the beginnings the orientations as
well as straight through the agency
budget process um Etc um if I just put
on 2021 real quick you can see we'll
have a wealth of information here on the
various versions of the budget as it
goes through um one of the most
important documents that that we do
develop is called the Surplus statement
the Surplus statement which um estimates
provides the estimated Revenue as well
as the Appropriations as um approved by
the various bodies to show the public
and and show the members so they can
vote on a balanced budget plan um if I
I'm going to take you to revenue
documents this is new page on our
website and chish Shay uh has worked to
put up this
uh um this specific Revenue
um page I think it's important we
separated our Revenue page out so it's a
little less um uh complicated but easier
to Define especially in this remote
environment we think we should have a
unique page uh but you can see various
if you want to go back you can see
various 20 and 21 May Revenue estimates
that the committee had during that
process as well as Revenue updates that
you received as ear um as uh soon back
as November 2020 um Senate ways means
also any documents that they had based
on a December 16th meeting um the
handout that I'm going to uh show you
today is under Revenue documents 2022
2023 if I click on that you can see that
Jen and Chris and Kevin Ripple in our
office have provided a January 21
economic briefing so members of the
public or other members who are um
watching or uh attending uh they can go
to our website to go to um to find those
documents I'm going to clip
uh the document that I will go over
really quickly um to show kind of what
we call a snapshot now we call this a
snapshot a surplus statement snapshot um
this is to compare actual results versus
what the budget writers um had developed
back in 2019 when the budget was passed
as you remember the budget was veto to
the 2021 budget was actually signed into
law uh right at the end of September
setember so it was a three-month delay
in starting that budget uh due to the
veto but then an agreement was reached
uh the budget was put into place for 20
and 21 um and then several months later
the pandemic hit and so the uh budget
rate is really we're dealing with the
delay with the veto and then all of a
sudden in March we saw the New Hampshire
economy uh turn on its head and
basically everything changed um if we
look at what happened during the budget
process the budget had assumed uh a
beginning balance a beginning balance is
any carry forward balance uh from the
previous fiscal year budget had assumed
about
$21.5 million from the previous year and
that's because of your your 19 fiscal
year 19 revenues were um over budget by
close to a couple hundred million
dollars uh so they performed really well
you remember the last two fiscal years
prior to this year uh taxes were
performing extremely well especially uh
business taxes um in meals and rooms uh
total revenue coming in uh 262
6.1 offset by total Appropriations in
the budget uh which were about 2.86 s
estimated lapse is really an assumption
that although since the budget is a
two-year planning document uh passed in
2019 ahead of time there are programs uh
that don't begin right away there are
positions that um do not begin right
away and as a result you do have laps
laps being unspent Appropriations and so
every budget process as we develop a
surplus statement for the current Bal
budget there is an assumed lapse amount
um typically in the 3% range um and
that's just from you know it's the
nature of the process trying to predict
two years ahead of time uh total net
appropriations of about 2.8 uh million
knowing that the there was a beginning
balance that was anticipated of 200
million uh so cumulative ending balance
of about $ 27.1 million as part of a
budget process any even number fiscal
year any balance remaining at the end or
any deficit remaining at the end carries
forward into the next year the second
year of the bayum and so as far as uh 20
the budget was based on the fact that 20
would end with a positive $7.1 million
uh Surplus and that carried forward into
21 which we'll see in a couple moments
and that balanced the budget obviously
any variance from that good or bad does
change the budget picture you can see
the caffer the comprehensive annual
financial report which was released at
the end of uh December showed um the
actual results so the the budget writers
had a plan in September of 19 the uh
fiscal year 20 ended on June 30th 2020
and the actual results audited uh at the
end of December showed a small variance
in the beginning balance of about 2. 6
million really has to do with timing of
some lapsing of funds based on uh the
previous budget uh total revenue this is
where ways means will focus the variance
was $15.9 Million uh below so a a
deficit in the revenue portion of the
budget of about $15.9 million um which
is actually better than originally
anticipated I think there was a number
floating around even even higher and so
the year ended uh 105 9 million below
revenue for 20 uh as far as uh
Appropriations a small variance in
appropriations of about 12.9 million in
additional Appropriations things like um
settlements um payouts for retire
positions as um abandoned property
claims Etc there is's always a slight
variation um and then estimated laps you
remember I talked about the laps the
unspent funds um the unspent funds even
though revenues are short by about $15.9
million the estimated lapse was 102.7 so
that was a variance of $46 million which
is to the good that is a a positive
variance on the appropriation side and a
lot of that had to do with the fact that
um we had positions uh usually take
about three months to fill you did have
the three-month delay in um the passage
of the budget you did have a three-month
delay in starting programs up so there
was additional expenditure Laps on top
of that uh Health and Human Service say
did receive additional federal funds um
for the federal matching assistance
percentage or the so-called fmap of 6.2%
from Medicaid which did help uh HHS beat
their laps targets at the beginning of
the year and then the so-called Gap and
other adjustments in accounting term
these are liabilities um that adjust
based on instead of cash these are
actually uh payments or liabilities that
are attributable to 20 so they may have
occurred in 21 but they are they do have
to be cting against 20 because it's
based on that activity um so actually
cumulative vending balance on June 30th
was a Nega 54.4
million so what what we had to take into
account when we do our variance for the
LBA snapshot is yes it was a negative of
54.4 but we do remember that the budget
had uh counted on 27.1 million carrying
for it for 21 to have a balanced budget
because that $ 27.1 million did not
exist because there was a deficit of
54.4 million there's actually a negative
variance of 81.5 million so if you were
to look at the cafre if you hear um any
um presentations or read any articles
you'll hear about us the state ending 20
with a roughly an$ 81.5 million
deficit and so that's a budget deficit
of 81.5 moving quickly into 21 with what
we know now you can see in the yellow up
top 81.5 million uh deficit to begin um
estimated revenues to date this is a
number again this is a snapshot this
number is going to change uh rows four
through seven are really uh those are
what ways of means will focus on um 21
is the first uh year of a balanced
budget plan so the 22 and 23 budget also
has to take into account how does the
current fiscal year um how does that
present itself and if there is any
deficit at the end of 21 part of the
balanced budget Law requires that any
deficit be made up of by the budget
writers when they develop their 2223
budget um and so that's it's an
important piece of information we know
year to date through December uh the
state is $ 54.3 million up in general
and education trust fund Revenue um
again this is halfway through the year
you'll find out in on ways and means
that um we can't just extrapolate this
forward March and April are huge Revenue
months um for uh business taxes as as
well as other various taxes and so there
are times where you do end with a
positive variance in Revenue um halfway
through the fiscal year and you end up
in a totally opposite position so that's
something I think your house ways Means
Committee and Senate ways Means
Committee will be paying attention to
obviously this year um and I think you
have great presenters coming up
commissioner step after me shortly uh
which will be able to provide you with
uh better information as you develop
your 21 estimates so right now as we
stand a positive variance of 54.3 so for
the purpose of a snapshot a point in
time look um that is a positive offset
to the negative variance of the 815 and
then we have our budget Appropriations
our estimated laps right now a little
earlier in the year to figure out if the
state will laps above or Beyond um the
75.4 the budget writers had assumed we
typically in the second year of a bium
the laps or the unspent Appropriations
are a little higher uh than the previous
year a lot of that has to do with um
so-called carry forwards or or unlapsed
Appropriations from the first year that
carry into the next year um a lot of the
HHS accounts as well as some debt
service accounts do not lapse at the end
of 20 so if there are any lapsing or
unspent funds you would uh recognize
that in 21 and then other Appropriations
a negative 15.9 12 and a half that has
to do with the fact that budget writers
assumed HHS would have a12.5 million uh
budget reduction each year to meet their
$25 million back of the budget um
requirement uh that the budget writers
had put in however HHS was able to meet
all of that requirement in 20 so they
satisfied the back of the budget
requirement of the 25 million so no bi
anyal impact uh but because you did that
was a positive uh variance in 20 you do
have to account for the fact that there
will be no further budget reduction in
21 um current year balance of about 12
A5 uh offset from the negative balance
carried forward the
54.4 for cumulative ending balance for
the year
41.9 um if you can see um if you go
through the variance column the 81 A5
offset by the 54.3 in total revenue
offset by net appropriations of 15.9
ends with a $ 43.1 million uh budget
variance uh however when the budget
writers developed their budget they did
have a small cushion of about $1.2
million in uh additional funds that 1.1
of which would go to the rainy day fund
another 0.1 or about $60,000 and it
upstand the education trust
fund rainy day fund balance uh based on
the kaffer estimates is
115.5 so as we stand here today there
are sufficient funds in the r day fund
should the legislature
decide um to draw from the rainy day
fund to balance their budget and the
reason I say should although any deficit
can be made up from the rainy day fund
since the uh budget is in possession of
the legislature they can also uh make a
decision not to tap the rainy day fund
or tap it for a portion of the deficit
and then handle any remaining deficit in
22 and 23 and so that's something will
be working with the Committees uh over
uh the next couple of U few months
actually next few months and if that
were the case today even with the $4
41.9 million deficit the state could
technically end 21 with um still money
left over in the rainy day fund key is
though what's going to happen with
revenues we know based on your 20 um FY
20 uh 21 and in November of 20 Dr came
through with Revenue estimates that
could be uh 16 million high for what
they collect or $56 million below uh
plan um other non-d Revenue estimates
could be another 20 million below plan
so that's going to vary um if the state
were to just hit plan uh this 54.3
million would go away uh you would still
have enough in um the ren day fund
unless there are additional expenditures
typically there are another $8 million
in expenditures that come through the
fiscal committee um or through statutory
um allowances that do hit the uh the
balance sheet um and so that's Bas I'll
wrap that up and open to any questions
that the committee may
have presentative major make sure that
you
unmute
I don't see any hands raised uh for
questions and it
is 9:29 so maybe we go into the
introductions for the next
phase which will be U from the
Department of Revenue
Administration and Lindsay stepp who's
the
commissioner she received her master's
of business administration degree from
Pou State
University after receiving her BS in
economics from Trinity College in
hawford Connecticut Lindsay served as
director business services for the
information technology services
department at Plymouth State University
and previously worked at the Department
of Revenue Administration as a financial
analyst Lindsay began her career at
Ernest and Young LLP as an inter
International tax and transfer pricing
consultant so Lindsay will bring us up
to speed on the Department of Revenue
Lindsay thank you representative major
good morning for the record lindsy step
commissioner at the Department of
Revenue I'm here in my office in conquer
give me just a second I will share my
screen
okay is everyone able to see the
presentation yeah thumbs up okay
perfect okay so good morning again thank
you for having me today
um what I plan to do this morning is to
give you an overview of the a little
brief overview of the Dr talk through
some of the taxes um that we we we
administer so the Dr administers 14
taxes for the state which represents
approximately 78% or just shy of two
billion of the audited Revenue collected
education trust funds
in20 the Dr has important insights into
the performance of the significant
Revenue sources but we La capacity to
perform more complex EIC predictions so
my goal this morning is to give you an
overview of the taxes what we've seen in
the past what we've seen year to date
how we believe covid has impacted some
of our taxes so that you have a
foundation for the information that
you'll be hearing over the course of
today and tomorrow with respect to
specific economic
predictions the presentation is going to
follow um a pretty consistent outline as
we move through the taxes we'll talk
about year-to-date revenues we'll talk
about factors that impact or affect the
taxes and we'll show you um a 10-year
Trend versus where that Trend or how
that Trend looks compared to
plan so we will jump right in to the
meals and rentals
tax so the M&R tax is levied on
consumers for the purchase of taxable
meals accommodation rentals as well as
motor vehicle rentals the tax is
collected by the operator or the
restaurant owner for instance and
remitted to the Dr on a monthly
basis there is a school building Aid
Debt Service that's a monthly transfer
that comes out of M&R uh before it's
reported at the end of the month the
transfer was just under uh 15 million
per year in fiscal year 12 but that
amount has been gradually decreasing to
11 a. half million in fiscal year 20 and
we're current currently at 8.3 million
in fiscal year 21 and as I mentioned
that amount is divided evenly among the
12 months and we deduct that each month
before reporting the final Revenue at
the end of the
month so audited M&R tax revenue
continued to ecrease over the past few
years until the covid-19 pandemic hit we
saw a 5.4% increase in fiscal year 2018
over
2017 a 5.5% increase in 2019 over
2018 however we saw a 99.9% decrease in
fiscal year 2020 over fiscal year
2019 for fiscal year 21 actual revenue
for the first six months is about
21.3% below plan and 16.6 below prior
year factors that can affect M&R
obviously covid um we'll talk a little
bit more about that on the next slide um
the weather can have an impact Sunny
Summers colorful Fall Foliage and snowy
Winters are all good things for M&R um
also the economy so when the economy is
thriving M&R tax is usually up so people
have more disposable income when we see
higher levels of employment we usually
see um increased M&R
tax specifically mentioning unemployment
um in the US unemployment was 6.7% in
November of 2020 with New Hampshire at
3.8% versus um a year prior the US was
at 3.5% and New Hampshire was at 2.6 so
obviously the increase in unemployment
um due to primarily the covid-19
pandemic has also seen as we've seen an
impact to the meals and rentals
tax for specific Co effects on M&R
obviously General impact the
stay-at-home order that we saw in the
spring restrictions on restaurants and
restrictions on hotels HS during that
time um as I mentioned the economy when
unemployment is high uh we can see a
decrease in meals and rentals tax and if
if restaurants were forced to close um
in recent months that would obviously
impact the
revenue um some changes in Behavior we
obviously saw the shift to outdoor
dining um in the spring and summer
months and into the fall that was
helpful for M&R that allowed folks even
um given the restrictions to still be
able to dine out and um remit the meals
and rentals tax also expanded takeout
right you've seen a lot of restaurants
that historically might not have done a
large takeout business kind of pivot
they've done a great job and expanded
the takeout options that they have
available which again would be subject
to the meals and Rental tax we have seen
shifts from sitdown restaurants to fast
food so when we look
at the data on an individual basis um at
the end of each month we see that the
impact to sit down restaurants When
comparing to the prior year is more
significant than the impact of fast food
um by and large fast food restaurants
are operating in close to a similar um
volume as they were a year ago but
obviously sit down restaurants have seen
a decrease on the rental side we've seen
a shift from hotels um to camps and
Cottages through rental agents so again
comparing year-over-year last year hot
when you compare hotel stays from this
year to last year you'll see a decrease
but when you look at um rental agents
who might rent out a camp or a cottage
on a lake or in the mountains um or the
use of Airbnb or similar platforms for
instance you'll see um in some cases an
increase but at the very least similar
volume to the prior year so the effects
of covid on the meals and rentals tax
can differ um when you look at that
specific um functions that the various
operators provide or how they're
delivering their their their
services in terms of our future outlook
obviously the lifted restrictions or not
imposing any additional uh restrictions
uh allow us to have a little bit more of
a positive outlook in the future
obviously the deployment of vaccine um
and getting people more comfortable to
be able to go out in public and dine or
to travel and stay in hotels and just
the general Improvement in the economy
um as well as any federal stimulus
that's provided that would help
businesses stay afloat or help people um
have more disposable income so that they
can spend it on things that may be
taxable under the meals and rentals
tax this shows a breakdown of the meals
and rentals tax so the blue section are
meals The yellow section is rooms the
light gray at the very top is motor
vehicles and at the bottom is the
commission um that operators are able to
retain if they um remit and file their
taxes on a timely manner um so what that
looks like at the end of fiscal year 20
about 80.4% of our Revenue was from
meals 177% from rooms and 2.6% from
Motor Vehicles so again meals tends to
be the primary category rooms next and
then a smaller amount for motor vehicles
and we've kind of shown a history here
so you can see what that's look like
over
time and lastly for M&R this is the
10year trend um you'll see a gradual
increase in M&R it's been a strong
performing tax as we've been in many
years of economic expansion um in good
Economic Times you will see that dip
from fiscal year 19 to fiscal year 20
that is primarily due to covid um our
fiscal year 21 Revenue plan is
386.3 and you can can see that at least
with the trend of fiscal year 20 we are
unlikely to um meet that plan for this
year this really is one of the primary
taxes that has had a negative effect um
due to the covid-19
pandemic um Mr chair if it's okay with
you I'll just pause for a moment to
answer any questions um before moving on
to the next
tax
representative major it looks like
representatives of brammy and Tucker
have
questions representative bronley yep hi
lay the presentation so far so when we
look at the chart right on the screen
right now that's exclusive of the school
building Aid Debt
Service that is correct that will be the
final audited Revenue so that is with
the school building Aid removed so when
we look at this 10-year pattern uh
you're saying that the school building
Aid Debt Service payment is going
down
um that does have an effect on this a
bit right correct right so with the
decreased payment you would obviously
the the slope of the curve would would
change slightly as the payment has
evolved over time um General the general
trend is consistent okay thank you sure
representative Tucker yes uh
I I remember this is meals in rooms is
this a am I wrong or have you changed it
to rentals to include motor
vehicles um the reference uh changes
between within the statute so meals and
rooms and meals and rentals are both the
same things we use the term kind of
interchangeably I see in here in the
North Country the split between meals
and rooms is quite um prominent so
knowing that that there is you know
these two categories is very important
here correct that's a great Point um and
when we meet with the committee in
Greater detail to start talking about
Revenue estimates we have information at
the county level um and so we can
provide that information to you so you
can see how the split between meals and
rentals is different between the
counties okay one more question uh
representative
Ames yeah thank you um so I'm wondering
wondering about the uh facilitators of
rentals of homes the Airbnb and other
entities like that and whether you're
actually collecting revenues from them
and there's also a parallel to the A
Automobile rental side where there are
entities that are uh enabling rentals I
think mostly of homeown uh you know
individual owned
Autos yeah
sure so there is some guidance available
on our website um for um people that are
renting their homes through Airbnb
versus through other platforms um
because who collects the tax and who
pays the tax is different um for certain
operators so that guidance is available
on our website and um there is
legislation that was introduced last
session um that did not make it into the
Omnibus bills at the end of the session
but I believe it'll be reintroduced this
year to clarify the taxability
of Motor Vehicles that are rented
through third parties similar to um your
airbnbs for the rental of rooms or homes
yes that that Bill's been introduced the
ways and means and we be we'll be
dealing with that this year
great U one more time for one more
question sure represent
Aly represent
Aly
okay then apologize I um I just had a
call from a constituent trying to make a
complaint about something totally
unrelated
um on my my question was whether on with
this chart we couldn't tell uh pretty
much we've always said that rooms and
meals uh especially
was mostly people inside the state that
were paying it does this give us some
kind of an idea of how true that is
since we're now in this situation where
everybody's supposed to quarantine if
they go between state
borders um so we have never known for
certain um who the consumers are because
again when you go out to eat at a
restaurant um or rent a hotel room you
pay pay the tax to that operator So to
that restaurant or to that hotel and
then that operator remits the tax to us
um so I think in the past we've been
able to make some assumptions based on
some travel and tourism data or just
general comments about the economy and
about people's um actions or habits or
behaviors about who the ultimate
consumers are but unfortunately that's
not something that's reported directly
to us although you do make a very good
point that in theory if folks are
following um guidance from other states
they may not be able to travel into New
Hampshire to say go out to eat or to
stay at a hotel or to rent um a house
for a week and so that is likely
contributing to the decrease in the
meals and rentals tax that we're seeing
Senator
gerer unmute yourself Senator there we
go thank you Mr chairman um uh
commissioner is there anything in his
historically within the records of uh
the department that would reflect any
kind of a similar catastrophe and
perhaps give us some guidance as to re
recovery rates and in the different
types of
Revenue so um this is probably true for
all of the taxes um in general but this
the impact of covid and this recession
is obviously not like anything else that
we have really seen
um the last significant economic
downturn was in 2008 2009 um so we can
look back at that and see the general
trend of recovery um when we do talk
about our specific Revenue estimates
coming up over the next few weeks and
months at the various committees um
we'll talk about some of the assumptions
that we made um with respect to how this
tax might recover one thing that is
different from prior recessions is we
believe that there's probably some pent
up demand um because on one hand folks
may not have the disposable income
depending on how Co has impacted them to
go out to eat on the other hand they may
have the income but they're just not
able to or they don't feel comfortable
um going out to eat you know I for one
have not stepped into a restaurant since
um July and in that case it was eating
Outdoors so I certainly will be one of
the first in line um when things do
improve um to enjoy a nice meal out to
eat so that pint of demand I think is
something that is unlike other
recessions or downturns that we've seen
and we will try to factor that into our
Revenue
estimates representative
yly Jordan yeah I trying to get there
keeping on the wrong button there um
regarding the meals Rooms To Go back to
Edith's question uh Mrs steep the or
commissioner
step is there any way to break out from
where the meals and rooms um revenue is
coming from that is I know from the
parking lot of the restaurants I go to
in
Hudson a lot more Massachusetts plates
than there are New Hampshire plates and
I'm sure that's the same uh over in
Salem and even up into
Manchester um the question
is even though Massachusetts has this
quarantine thing which everyone ignores
because they they shop in New Hampshire
and we're benefiting greatly from uh uh
their uh mentality down there um can we
break it up a little bit that way to
find to see if there's a difference
between let's say uh uh the meals and
room tax revenue um two years ago from
conquered and two years ago from from uh
Hudson Salem the Southern
Tier we can um we typically look at it
on a county basis um it can be a little
tricky um if you start looking at
specific municipalities because of
various reporting um for instance a
chain of restaurants May submit a
Consolidated return that may attribute
all of their revenue to conquered even
though they have locations and licenses
in multiple parts of the state
um so that's why we do typically look at
the county level but yes we can
definitely break it down by County we
can break it down into meals and rooms
we can break it down into some of the
larger categories in meals and rooms as
I mentioned um full service dining as
opposed to fast food full service
restaurants as opposed to rental agents
um and so we can definitely dive into
that data and I think you will start to
see that there are the impact of the
counties um are different and so we will
have that prepared and happy to talk to
the committee about that when we get
further into the revenue estimating
process follow up on that
nor go ahead yeah would that be
beneficial to us in trying to estimate
under a restricted uh environment of uh
sales uh as to determining whether or
not U there should be tax decrease or
tax increase well you know you know what
I'm talking about as as far as
um this this border um concept because
Portsmouth is going to benefit from the
strictness of Maine and Susan Lebanon is
going to benefit uh uh from what's
Happening across the river over in
Vermont
so this should be beneficial to us am I
correct on
that M St I I believe so that's
definitely we have been looking at the
data and we are happy to um share that
with you and walk through with you you
know what we're seeing so I I think
that's a very good idea okay okay
commissioner I think we can go
on the next tax we're going to talk
about is the real estate transfer tax
the tax on the sale transfer or granting
of property at a rate of a $150 per $100
of price or consideration for the trans
for the transfer um it is split 75 cents
is the obligation of the purchaser and
75 cents is the obligation of the
seller R has increased in recent years
we saw a 5.3% in 20 18 2.5% in 2019 and
3.7% in 2020 um over the prior
years uh for fiscal year 21 actual
revenue for the first six months of the
year is
14.6% ahead of fiscal year um 21 plan
and 7.4% ahead of fiscal year 2020 um on
audited Revenue year to date the reason
why those percentages look like they're
a little off or a little inconsistent is
there was a new transfer of $5 million
that was implemented in fiscal year 21
to the affordable housing fund so that
full $5 million transfer was performed
on October 1st and so that's why you'll
see that when you're comparing to Prior
year um it looks like we're not as head
as much as when you compare to plan plan
did take into account that
transfer uh factors that can affect R
obviously the economy um you need to
have the ability um to buyer sell a home
low interest rates they're currently at
historic lows
2.77% in November of 2020 inventory
levels the homes need to be on the mar
Market in order for them to sell um the
shift that we've been seeing from Urban
to more rural areas um covid has been
helpful um in this with this respect uh
I think as people look to move out of
the cities and move into um more rural
areas such as New Hampshire and then
obviously property values um we property
values were one
84.9 billion uh was the equalized value
for New Hampshire on April 21st of 2020
and that was compared to 175. n billion
uh the year before so almost a 10
billion doll increase in the total
equalized value of properties in just a
year obviously um with r as I said the
homes need to be on the market in order
for them to sell we're concerned about
inventory and sales volumes um and then
on the other hand the sales price um
impacts the amount of R collected as
well and so those can kind of go hand
inand um what we are generally seeing
right now I'll switch to the next slide
with covid is that we are starting to
see some um inventory constraints but
the values or the sales prices are very
high and so those are kind of balancing
each other out if we start to if the
inventories are are less and the sales
volumes decrease and the values decrease
as well then um we would see a negative
impact to the real estate transfer tax
so real estate transfer tax was an area
where I was at least concerned there may
be some impact during the stay-at-home
order um but really the industry pivoted
very quickly to doing remote or no
contact sales
um folks have been buying homes without
ever stepping foot in them um virtual
chours uh for for houses have been very
popular and then even a fully remote
closing has been able to occur as well
so I think that has helped the real
estate transfer tax um the sales to
occur and the tax to stay um at the
levels that we're
seeing obviously the economy will play
an impact on the real estate transfer
tax unemployment higher unemployment to
typically leads to fewer people um
looking to move or buy or sell
homes um larger savings due to fewer um
expenses uh is a good thing for the real
estate transfer tax if folks have some
money in the bank they might be trying
to save for that first home or maybe
save to purchase a new or bigger home
and the savings that people um in many
cases are realizing during covid-19 may
be helpful to that I mentioned in terms
of changes in Behavior the virtual home
sales um a lot of folks are doing home
improvements um maybe doing some work on
their home and then looking to put it on
the market and obviously the ability to
work from home and a movement away from
the urban centers have drawn folks to
New Hampshire um I believe as a place
that they would like to live Recreation
lots of outdoor activities here and
they're no longer tied to that office
necessarily in um an urban area say in
Massachusetts in terms of our future
future outlook obviously lifted
restrictions um a vaccine improving the
economy um these are all things that we
think will help the real estate transfer
tax um but I will note a area of concern
is the slowing of home sales due to the
inventory um at some point I anticipate
that the homes are just not going to be
on the market even if people want to buy
them um also New Hampshire Winters um
can be slow for new home construction um
and so there is likely going to be a
point here where just the inventory um
starts to potentially um decrease some
of the tax and that we've been seeing
due to the home
sales looking at the 10year revenue
Trend R's been doing great um again
coming out of the 2008 2009 recession
those years of economic expansion were
were good for the real estate transfer
tax um you can see that our fiscal year
21 plan at 158.4 million is very close
to where we landed um in fiscal year
2020 so I would say it is likely that we
will um at least meet if not exceed plan
here even with the concerns about
inventory R is just in a very good place
um at this
point and I will pause there for any
real estate transfer uh tax questions we
have a question from senator
rosenwall
thank you Mr chairman good morning
commissioner can the department quantify
for us um of fiscal year 20's um
performance above plan what percentage
was due to um increased number of sales
and what percentage of the performance
increase was due to increased value of
sales quick question that's a great
question um so we do track on a monthly
basis the volume of sales um and again
we track that by County so we can see
what's happening in the various counties
so we have the sales volume data and we
can compare that to how the how the tax
performed as a whole and so that will
get at whether it was solely driven just
by volume or whether you know for
instance if the volume was exactly the
same as the prior year but the tax on
increase that would be a result of
increased values and so again when we
come before the Committees to do the
more in-depth analysis with respect to
the revenue estimating we can certainly
provide that information and help you
dissect um what that means but we have a
very long history um on how the the
number of transactions by County um and
so we can definitely dive into that
thank you representative
Tucker yes uh it's a great presentation
here in the North Country anecdote
toally sales or Price say Rose far
higher on sales where there was suitable
Broadband is there any way that you can
quantify that as we talk about the need
for Broadband it would be nice to have a
base of
facts that's a good point let me think
about that a little bit um we may be
able to
Break um the data down by municipality
and so you could compare those
municipalities with Bron band access to
those without um and we can see what
we're seeing in terms of the volume of
the sales and maybe extrapolate from
that the the sale prices so let us do a
little bit of digging on that one thank
you representative
janigan janin I'm sorry thank you Mr Mr
chairman
um my my question on this would be what
percent is the uh real estate transfer
tax of the total
revenue oh good question I don't have
that immediately in front of me but when
we come for our next presentation in
front of house ways and means we're
going to show you a nice pie chart that
has it all broken out for the various
taxes so we will have that
information thank you Mr chairman
followup
followup um thank you um and then when
you said property values went from 1.75
billion to 184 billion from 2019 to 2020
that is that the total property value of
all properties in New Hampshire that is
so that's the total equalized value that
we report in our um annual report yep so
that's total value for the whole state
thank
you uh any further questions on the real
estate
tax I don't see any so
commissioner okay moving on to the
tobacco
tax so the tobacco tax is levied on each
package of cigarettes at
$1.78 um $1.78 per pack of 20 and $223 C
per pack of 25 um you will see that as a
little stamp on the bottom of a package
of cigarettes the tobacco tax is also
levied on other tobacco
products at a rate of 65.0 3% of the
wholesale sales price and so this would
be your loose tobacco your pipe tobacco
um anything that's really not in the
form of a cigarette and not in a pack of
20 or
25 um also we now tax e ecigarettes and
that went into effect on January 1st of
2020 it is levied on both the closed
systems and the open systems so the
closed system where you buy just one
piece of or the E Cig cigarette is just
one piece um that tax rate is three
cents per millimeter on the volume of
liquid or other substance that contains
nicotine in the cartridge or container
the open system is where you have like a
refillable you might buy the liquid
separately and insert it into a system
and that is taxed at 8% of the wholesale
sales price of the container of liquid
or other substance that's containing
nicotine
the composition of tobacco tax revenue
is changing historically it was
primarily stamp sales so packs of
cigarettes um but in recent years other
tobacco products has grown and currently
makes up 7.7% of the tobacco tax revenue
compared to fiscal year 2012 when other
tobacco products made up 3.4% of Revenue
so again seeing a little bit of that
shift away from cigarettes into other
tobacco
products um factors that can affect the
tobacco tax crossborder elasticity we
have the lowest tobacco tax rate in the
region so we see a fair amount of crossb
sales also the trend as I mentioned in
stamp sales we typically have over the
years have seen a decrease in um stamp
sales of approximately 3% year-over-year
um but recently uh Massachusetts banded
mentholated products are all flavored
tobacco products that went into effect
on June 1st of 2020 and we have
certainly seen an increase in tobacco
tax revenue due to that we have uh
spoken with not only wholesalers um who
essentially collect and pay the tax but
also with retailers and um New Hampshire
wholesalers have seen an increase um in
flavored tobacco product um requests
from their retailers and retailers have
also mentioned especially those along
the border that they've seen an increase
in sales um primarily of those
mentholated um
tobacco
products so as I mentioned audited
tobacco tax revenue historically has
decreased year-over-year 3 to 4% in 2018
and
2019 however in fiscal year 2020 we did
see a 5.7% increase over fiscal year
19 um that I believe is largely due to
the uncertainty in the spring as the
covid-19 pandemic hit we saw a lot of
wholesalers stocking up um on their
purchases of stamps uh obviously the
uncertainty of you know would the Dr be
open to uh for us to be able to purchase
stamps we remained open throughout the
pandemic and the stay-at-home order um
but I definitely there was some
uncertainty around the business model of
the wholesalers and what their um
abilities were going to be to continue
stamping and distributing product so
there was certainly some stocking up
there that we saw at the end of fiscal
year 20 um and then for fiscal year 21
actual revenue for the first six months
is 24.8% above plan and
26.2% above fiscal year 2020 again I
think this is a combination of the ban
in Massachusetts on flavored tobacco
products in particular your mentholated
cigarettes um and
also um I have heard anecdotally that um
the covid-19 pandemic although smoking
certainly a risk factor for covid um the
stress of what we all have been going
through over the past almost you know 10
months um might not be the most
conducive environment to people for
people to decide to quit smoking so
we're just not seeing that decline in
stamp sales that we've seen in past
years also on this slide just for
reference I have included what
ecigarette Revenue has looked like over
the last six months so in the last six
months um we've collected about 2.1
almost 2.2 million and that is an
increase over the 1.2 million that we
collected during the first six months of
the taxation of ecigarettes that is
expected there is typically a bit of a
learning curve um when a new product
becomes taxable um but we're looking at
approximately 300 to 400,000 a month in
ecigarette uh tax
revenue this will show the trend of
tobacco tax stamp revenue from F year 11
through fiscal year
2020 um I will note in here there are
some rate changes so that significant
decrease you see from fiscal year 11 to
fiscal year 12 that is a rate change and
then the rate increased from fiscal year
13 to fiscal year 14 again you see that
bump but starting in fiscal year 16 17
18 19 we saw some downward Trends in
those stamp sales and that's what I was
uh speaking to with the 3 to 4% decrease
but then fiscal year 20 we did see um
that increase primarily due to the
increase in stamp sales we saw in the
spring and then here's the chart for
other tobacco products this very clearly
shows um the increase that we've seen um
in the sale of those products the again
the change from fiscal year 11 to 12
that decrease that is the result of a
rate change there was a rate increase
from 13 to 14 and then we've seen a
pretty steady increase from fiscal year
14 to fiscal year 19 that significant
jump that you'll see from fiscal year 19
to 20 remember that's the start of H
taxation of ecigarettes as
well and then lastly the tobacco tax
revenue 10-year
Trend again you can see some fluctuation
from fiscal year 11 through fiscal year
14 15 16 for fiscal year 16 to 19 we did
see that decrease um and that is what we
were intending to see you can see that
fiscal year 21 plan um was just about
equal to fiscal year 19 so I think we
anticipated the tax to stabilize just a
little bit with the taxation of
ecigarettes um but we did see that bump
in fiscal year 20 tobacco tax cons
continues to perform well we will talk
about that some more in Greater detail
in front of the Committees when you're
doing your Revenue
estimates um we anticipate it will
probably level off at some point but it
is one of the shining stars uh lately um
due to covid um rather than a negative
impact we're seeing I think I believe a
positive impact um on the tobacco
tax I'm happy to pause here and answer
any
questions any any questions on the
tobacco tax um representative bramy
Pat Patrick you're you're
muted sorry about that commissioner um
so we spent a lot of time last year on
the taxation of Vape products last year
uh we had a lot of testimony from vape
shops but I've heard through the graef
find that a lot of the vape shops are uh
didn't make it through this this uh time
a lot of them have closed have you got
the same read on that I have not heard
that yet but we can certainly look into
um what our licenses look like and if
we've seen some closures um in our uh
Vape Shop licenses so we can certainly
dig into that right thank you Senator
Daniels thank you Mr chairman uh
commissioner as as looking at your chart
there on the uh the revenue coming in
and I guess the as we look look like as
we lowered the uh tax on it there was
less Revenue are we seeing a trend on
that or uh there's also the argument
that when we lower the tax it we
increase because we get over the over
the bard of sales uh which one is more
accurate um I would say given that we
already have the lowest tax in the
region that it is probably more likely
that when we lower the rate we just
decrease Revenue um I'm not sure that it
I think the people that are already
coming to New Hampshire um to get the
cheaper um cigarettes they're already
doing that most likely um there may be a
small amount um that do the math and
decide at the current rate it's not
enough and if it was 10 cents lower then
maybe they would um but I think it's
more likely that we have a good amount
of crossb sales at this point and
reductions to the rate are probably not
enough to to offset the decrease that we
see in
Revenue okay just one followup if follow
up okay uh so you don't see that uh the
more dispar uh more distance we have
between uh New Hampshire and neighboring
states that you would draw deeper from
within the bordering states to come to
New Hampshire for instance years ago I
heard of people coming from
Connecticut to to New Hampshire because
there there was such a difference
sure that is a good point um we can we
have the data for those surrounding
states um and their current tax rates
and so we will definitely present that
to the committee so you can kind of see
the the level of or the um actual
difference in the tax um between the
various States and you're right we may
see that um Connecticut is significant
enough that it could drive sales here um
I think what might be more likely is
what exactly what we're seeing with
Massachusetts as other states around us
ban certain products or restrict access
to products um if we don't make the same
corresponding change um we're likely to
see an increase in
sales thank you represent El me you want
to unmute
yourself thank you uh years ago and it
was actually Brian GB that came up with
this on that there was a a major
statistical relationship between our
amount of sales and the price of
gasoline and the price of Gasol because
it takes a lot of gasoline more gasoline
to get here from Connecticut or New York
where they were coming from some of them
uh and
um the price of gasoline is has been
pretty low since covid
started and do you see any relationship
there at the current time because we've
also got these travel restrictions which
apparently Massachusetts doesn't obey
but Maine and Vermont are pretty strict
about sure you're right about the the
effect of the price of gasoline um we
haven't done an updated analysis um with
respect to that um but I you're right
that that's certainly one of the factors
that could be impacting what we're
seeing for example with the ban in Mass
Massachusetts if gas if gasoline was
prohibitively expensive we not might not
be seeing the increase sales in those
Bann products that we're seeing here in
New Hampshire if gas was really
expensive so that is a very good
point Senator
Rosen you want to unmute thank you thank
you Mr chairman commissioner I'm really
um glad that you
mentioned anxiety and stress as a
potential driver for increased tobacco
use because that is documented that um
addictions cross substances too and that
um rates of smoking are are actually
higher among populations that
have uh a mental illness or a substance
use disorder and so my I'm wondering if
the department has had any discussions
with the Department of Health and Human
Services or is able to track for
example um the revenues for this tax in
the current fiscal year alongside of the
the numbers of people who are waiting
for an emergency psychiatric bed which
has shot way up during the pandemic is
there a way to look at
what the actual impact of increased
mental illness and substance use
problems um what that impact is on rates
of tobacco use sure that's a great point
we could certainly reach out to HHS and
review some of the documentation I was
speaking kind of more anecdotally but
I'm glad that I wasn't necessarily um
wrong in my assumption about the um
correlation between anxiety and smoking
um so we can certainly look into that
see if we can get some better data um or
some more specific data what will be a
little bit difficult is trying to parse
the difference between the impact of
anxiety or mental health on the rate of
smoking and this ban of products in
Massachusetts we kind of have two things
potentially happening at the same time
but we can certainly look into the data
and see if there's a way that we can
kind of pull it apart um or at least
make sure or try to confirm that the
general trend is consistent um with what
we're seeing thank
you okay I don't see any further
questions so um commissioner go on to
interest in dividends sure interest in
dividends tax so the interest in
dividends tax is assessed at a rate of
5% on interest in dividend income of
individuals Partnerships and
fiduciaries over the past three years
indd has performed well a 12.2% increase
year-over-year in 18 8.4 and 19 and 9.6
and
20 Fisco year 21 uh for the first six
months of the year is
31.9% ahead of plan and
34.1% of fiscal year 2020 I will note
that the 21 number um is net of a
99.2% anomalous receivable so I'm just
going to stop quickly and talk about
anomalous receivables um
they are most important in the interest
in dividends tax and in the business
taxes so when the state um produces the
caffer the final audited financial
report um we take Revenue that's
received in fiscal year um
21 that we receive in the first 60 days
where the underlying activity from that
Revenue occurred in the prior year and
we're able to pull that ount back in the
audited
financials what happened in fiscal year
21 is that as you may remember covid hit
right around April 15th um there was
pressure um to follow the federal due
dates the federal uh the IRS moved their
due dates from April 15th to July
15th here in New Hampshire we moved our
due dates from April 15th to June 15th
in order to take into into account the
fiscal year end of the state being on
June 30th the federal year end is not
until September so they didn't have that
same issue of potentially straddling
years so we move the date from April
15th to June
15th however not everyone followed that
June 15th date and we received in the
case of indd just over $ n million do of
Revenue um around July 15th that really
was due June
15th and so on a cash basis we are going
you're going to see that 9.2
million in the cash basis numbers that
the department produces and that will be
in the revenues until we get to the end
of the fiscal year and we perform the
accounting adjustment to remove it but
when you want to compare year-over-year
we did remove it from this analysis so
that you could really compare apples to
oranges because that 9.2 million that we
received in 21 really was supposed to
come in in 20 so it's just a timing
difference it gets a little complicated
with the accounting um when we spend
time with the Committees to talk about
your Revenue estimates we'll go into a
deeper dive about the anomalous
receivable we'll go through an
explanation again of why what happened
and why it's important and we'll talk
about what you need to do with that
amounts when you're looking to do your
Revenue
projections um factors that can affect
indd obvious VI ly the economy the stock
market um past federal tax reform um
some folks may remember what was
referred to as the fiscal cliff um where
pending tax changes um resulted in many
individuals and businesses accelerating
some dividends um and distributions uh
at the end of a calendar year in order
to um kind of head off some negative tax
impacts that were likely to occur um in
the following calendar year um so those
sort sorts of changes um Can impact the
timing of Revenue that we receive
obviously the amount of money in the
bank and interest rates um also play
into the interest in dividends
taxed um first I just wanted to show the
trend you see some fluctuations um in
2013 um 14 and 15 um that was due to
some changes in the tax that occurred at
the time but generally from 2016 forward
we're on a pretty consistent upward
Trend again 2020 end of the year ahead
of 21 plan so this is another tax where
I expect that we will at least meet if
not exceed plan the other thing I would
just note with respect to um the fact
that we are
31.9% ahead of plan year to
date the vast majority of interest in
dividends tax comes in in the last three
months of the year so April May and
June you have your April 15th due date
and then you have June 15th estimates
that are due so this tax as Mr Kane
indicated in his presentation is one
where you can see a positive um amount
of Revenue compared to plan in the early
part of the year but that may get eroded
because so much of the revenue is kind
of backloaded in the second half of the
year so still early with this TX
um hang tight will again do a deeper
dive into how the tax generally comes in
throughout the fiscal year when we do
additional presentations to the
Committees when you're doing your
Revenue
estimates looking at the breakdown of
interest and dividends tax over the past
10 years you'll see that we tax
distributions dividends federally tax
exempt interest income that's an
instance where for federal purposes it
is tax exempt but here at the state it
is taxable and then interest the
breakdown in tax year
2019 was
32.4% was distributions 43.2 were
dividends 8.1 was federal tax exempt
interest income and
16.2 was regular interest so again we
call it interest in dividends but it's
really dividends and distributions that
are the vast majority of the inputs for
this
tax and I will pause here with any
questions U representative
browny you want to unmute
yourself did that again I'm sorry
commissioner um sorry about that um we
got the new computer systems up and I
think it's for both business tax and
indd is that correct correct so let's
just talk about indd uh do you think
that with the new computer system I know
I know you do when you audit this tax
you go to the the individual's um
personal uh Federal returns is that
correct that is correct and does the new
computer system make that easier to do
and what I'm getting at is there going
to be more compliance for this tax
because of that that's a great point and
yes indd is an area we where we
anticipate to see um some improved
compliance with our new system so you're
correct that we routinely um identify
non-filers by comparing their federal
tax information to their state tax
information and for instance if you had
federally reported dividends
distributions and interest that are in
an excess of the thresholds here in New
Hampshire and you're a New Hampshire
resident we would expect to see a
corresponding New Hampshire interest and
dividends tax return when we don't we
will reach out and just you know gently
say could you help us understand you
know what we're missing missing and why
you haven't filed that process is fairly
manual at this point um given our
current system or our old system at this
point um interest in dividends and
business taxes went live in rims which
is our new Revenue information
management system at the beginning of
October and so we are able to slowly as
we ramp up our auditing post covid um
will be able to take advantage of the
efficiencies that we have in that new
system um with identifying compliance
issues or non or
non-filers thank you represent Aly you
want to un
yourself yes thank you on just to follow
up on that one before I ask the question
I had on in the past a lot of the people
that were caught this way had recently
moved into the state being told that
there wasn't an income tax therefore
they didn't have to worry about taxes at
all um and uh I think that with the
covid refugees coming into this state
particularly higher income ones that
have jobs that can be remote uh that uh
there should be quite a few of them
coming found this next year and but my
question was that I've noticed a huge
part of the revenues come from
Individual filers
and on they those people including me
are doing quarterly estimates uh based
on the previous
year and so uh it seems difficult to try
to project what we're going to see when
and at least for me most of the
distributions arrived arrive in December
with no
warning so uh I don't think a lot of
people are going to be changing their
quarterly estimates until they do their
final taxes and so the last two payments
the year are going to be
critical correct that is a good point
and again that is why I mentioned and we
will go into it in Greater detail how
revenue is received throughout the year
the April 15th return um and extension
due date will be critical for helping us
understand um what is happening with
interest and dividends tax and you're
right again those June estimates um I
can say that um you know fiscal year to
date through December um estimate
payments were 25% ahead of the prior
year um so it is looking like as you
mentioned many folks are making payments
consistent with the prior year and some
are even increasing them slightly um
we'll update that number at the end of
this month because January was an
estimate month for the interest in
dividends tax and so we should have some
um additional data on that when we
present in front of the committee later
this
month Senator Daniels thank you Mr
chairman commissioner what is the
threshold in New Hampshire for
indd that's a good
[Music]
question me one second it's
$2,400 uh dollar for an individual and
4,800 for
um joint
filers thank you and again that'll be
information that we provide to the
committee we'll do a deeper dive into
the taxes and we'll talk about the
thresholds for the various taxes the
amount of um exemptions that some taxes
might have Etc and we'll give it to you
in a nice um easy way so that you can
reference it in the
future commissioner before you go into
um utility property tax are are you
going to go over the schedules uh of
when to report these
taxes yes we will do that as well um in
our next presentation when we come
before um the house Ways and Means
Committee next week we'll talk about the
due dates so when various um taxes are
reported throughout the fiscal year
thank you because we have nine new
members up on our committee sure right
and I believe me I understand it can be
a steep learning curve um so again we'll
try to presented in a format um we'll
give you statutory references so you
know where to look if you have more
specific questions we'll talk about the
timing of filings and revenues we'll
talk about key exemptions thresholds Etc
and hopefully um in a way that you can
uh keep it and refer to it throughout
the session as you need it thank you all
right you you told the property
tax okay utility property tax so this is
a tax imposed on the value of utility
prop properties the rate is
$6.60 per $1,000 of value and the Dr
sets that value as of April 1st of each
year ubt Revenue has fluctuated a bit
over the past few years from an 88.2%
increase over the prior year in 18 to a
12.5% decrease in fiscal year 19 to a
99.6% increase in fiscal year 20 fiscal
year 21 actual revenue for the first 6
months is 4.8% ahead of plan and 88.5%
ahead of Prior
year tax year 2020 assessments are
38.9 million with a total property value
of 5.9 billion um this tax is pretty
consistent um year-to year um it all
gets deposited into the education trust
fund um but things that can impact the
tax is obviously the development of any
new renewable energy facilities which we
have seen in previous years the general
valuation of the utility property um
which goes into various valuation
methods and then energy pricing supply
and demand impact the value of these
properties as
well again questions smaller tax so I
just wanted to go over this briefly
happy to answer
questions uh since no questions
communication Services tax perfect
communication Services tax is a tax of
7% on all two-way
Communications in 2012 um the tax
excluded charges for internet access
which caused a significant decrease in
Communication Service tax
revenues um you can see that from fiscal
year 2009 to 2012 CST was between 76.5
million and 81 million after the change
from fiscal year 13 to fiscal year 17
Revenue was between
47.1 and 59.3 million so again the the
um exclusion of the taxability of
internet access resulted in that
decrease in
Revenue um but over the past three years
um Revenue has been much more consistent
43.4 million in 18 41.2 million in 19
39.3 million in
20 for fiscal year 21 actual revenue for
the first 6 months is about 8.8 below
plan and 4.6 below um United revenue of
the prior year part of that is due to a
timing issue um with some late payments
that we anticipate receiving this
month factors that affect um CST
decrease in landlines um you know
earlier uh or in Prior years many folks
had a landline and a cell phone um both
would have been taxable
now many folks have abandoned the
landline and only use their cell phone
um resulting in a decrease in taxable
two-way
Communications um modern pricing and
purchasing trends for Wireless
Communications again this shift to
wireless um and uh decrease in the use
of landmines um and then also the
inclusion of VoIP um and video
conferencing uh will help to stabilize
this tax and you can kind of see in
recent years um that it has become much
more stable um than it was in Prior
years again this is a smaller tax so I
don't have any charts I just wanted to
give a brief overview but I'm happy to
answer any
questions representative
Bry commissioner let me use an example
so is this Zoom service that we're using
taxable my understanding is yes um but I
am not com totally confident that all uh
video conferencing um is being
appropriately remitted to the state so
this is something that our audit
division is looking into okay thank
you that'll be an issue uh representa
Jen thank you Mr chairman um so the uh
decrease in landlines is causing a
decrease in Revenue why why are the why
are cell phones or mobile communication
not taxed in the same way they are
they're still taxable um it's just you
before you may have had two taxable
products you're landline and your cell
phone and now you only have one taxable
product I see okay thank so it's just
kind of the shift it's it's reducing the
tax base a little bit
right good question uh representative
elmy Susan you want to unmute
yourself mute
button um there's also um for those of
us that live on cable because it's the
only uh Broadband that we can get in our
areas uh the cable companies have
reduced within their packages the price
of uh landline access uh to almost
nothing and then they pay the tax on
that and they charge us a lot more for
internet and
television that's a good point so
obviously just the shift um even for
those with land lines the cost of having
a landline has decreased with those
Cable packages that some folks are able
to get good
point okay I don't see any further
questions so uh go on to the the big
ones the big one okay business taxes so
business taxes consist of actually two
taxes the business Enterprise tax and
the business profits
tax the bet is assessed on the sum of
all compensation PID to recruit interest
paid or ACR and dividends paid by the
business the BPT is assessed on income
from the conduct of business activity
within the
state so business profits tax conforms
to the Internal Revenue code of 1986 in
effect on December 31st 2016 for taxable
periods beginning on or after January
1st
2018 for all tax will periods beginning
on or after January 1st 2020 the
applicable version of the IRC will be as
of December 31st
2018 important thing to note there is
that the code in effect on December 31st
2018 cons uh includes the tax cut and
jobs act so that is kind of our update
from the Internal Revenue code prior to
the tax cut and jobs act to the Internal
Revenue code with the tax cut and jobs
act factors that affect business taxes
obviously the economy uh federal tax
reform um line 28 of a TA of a
business's federal tax return is the
starting point for their New Hampshire
tax return and uh while applying the
code that we um that we reference
mergers and Acquisitions can have tax
impacts credits and other exemptions
will have tax impacts and then obviously
any statutory changes um that we
consider uh throughout the year uh that
ultimately become
implemented recent statutory changes
um business tax rates you'll see a chart
in the presentation and on the screen
that gives you a history of the business
tax rates um there was a potential
trigger um that was uh going to go into
effect on January 1 of this year given
revenues um that the state received
however that trigger was not met so you
will see that the rate stayed the same
at 7.7% for BPT and 6% for bet
other notable statutory changes um
there's two here that relate to
apportionment so if you are a business
business that operates both within and
without the state so you're a regional
New England business all the way up to a
multinational business um if you operate
inside New Hampshire and outside New
Hampshire you need to apportion your
income to New Hampshire um so we need to
know what portion of your income is
attributable here and then we tax that
portion these two changes impact how a
portion Min is calculated so the first
is market-based sourcing and that is in
effect for taxable periods ending on or
after December 31st of this year this is
for intangibles and services um when
you're looking to determine where those
services or intangibles should be a
portioned you're going to look um to
your end customer at this point prior to
taxable period ending onor after
December 31st of 21 you would use What's
called the cost of performance method
and you would look to where those
Services were actually being
performed the other apportionment change
to note is single sales Factor
apportionment which um under current
statute would be taxable for periods
ending on or after December 31st of
2022 currently and up until that date um
New Hampshire calculates apportionment
based on sales property and payroll so
we look at your sales in the state we
look at your property that you own in
the state and we look at your payroll in
the state we double weight that sales
factor and then we divide um and that's
how we determine what portion of your
Revenue Pi is attributable here in New
Hampshire um with the single sales
Factor apportionment for taxable periods
ending on or after December 31st of 2022
the only thing that we're going to look
at is where your sales occur we're not
going to look any anymore at how much
property you have in the state or what
your payroll in the state is all we care
about is splitting your Revenue P based
on where your sales are
located so those are two things that are
fairly complicated topics a portion Min
uh definitely have it has its learning
curve and we will certainly work with
the committee to make sure everyone
understands what those changes
are here's just a history of business
tax revenue um in the chart for fiscal
year 11 through fiscal year
2020 um you will see business taxes do
fluctuate year to year um you'll see in
18 we had a pretty significant increase
um and again a bit of an increase in 19
we worked with the prior committee
during the prior um session to look at
some one-time revenues that we
anticipated occurring during that time
due to the federal tax cut and jobs act
um and then you see a decrease um in
fiscal year 20 and that is partially due
to um the beginning of
covid um but business tax revenues
fiscal year to date um for the first six
months of the year we are
14.3% above plan and
12.1% above fiscal year 2020 and again
we did remove the 18.3 million anomalous
receivable that I mentioned earlier um
we did remove that so you have a more
apples to apples comparison um in the
next slide we'll just go through kind of
the effects that covid-19 has had on
business taxes obviously for many
businesses the stay-at-home order um
hurt their business um some survived
some did not um there's less activity
generally in the economy and then
there's strain on businesses due to
restrictions on
employees in terms of what's happening
in the economy obviously the
unemployment rate plays a factor shift
in Behavior years of businesses um
Federal stimulus money and then state
aid programs there is was a fair amount
of money that was distributed to
businesses to help them through this
time in hopes that um businesses would
not have to close um and in large part I
think that was very helpful um when
we're talking about federal aid programs
obviously the PPP loans or grants and
the eidl loans are important in terms of
helping businesses through that
time in terms of changes in behaviors
certain businesses are thriving home
improvement stores big box stores um
anyone with an internet presence you
know if I can order it and it can show
up at my house um that's certainly a
good thing as I'm not going into many
stores at this point obviously
technology companies as we all
transition to working remotely um saw a
benefit and obviously medical providers
medical devices Etc um potentially
benefited from the covid-19
pandemic I think it is important to note
here in that sense that um unlike other
recessions this the pandemic and this
downturn in the economy really had a
desparate impact on businesses it didn't
impact all businesses the same some
businesses saw significant um reductions
in revenue and potentially did need to
close um even with the state aid it was
not state or federal aid it was not
enough for them to stay open other
businesses are thriving um and so it is
a very different work world when you
look at the various types of businesses
and I think that has partially
contributed to why we have not seen um a
large decrease or a significant impact
on business tax revenue that we were
originally potentially
anticipating
um also I will note and we will talk
more about this when we get into the
more specific presentations many of you
are probably familiar with our annual
report and the triangles that show the
number of businesses and how much money
businesses pay the punchline from from
those charts is that very few businesses
pay the vast majority of Revenue to the
state and so when you're seeing impacts
to smaller businesses Main Street
businesses mom and pop
shops they definitely contribute to the
New Hampshire economy and they pay
Revenue to the state but it is um not as
significant as some very large
businesses that pay a very large amount
of Revenue to the state and so when you
see impacts to those smaller businesses
we don't always see a direct reaction or
a direct correlation to the revenue um
that we
receive in terms of the future outlook
as we've said before lifted restrictions
the vaccine and just general Improvement
of the economy will help business taxes
kind of continue on this trend that
we're seeing which has been um pretty
consistent or has been pretty positive
at this point point this is just a graph
of the 10-year Trend you'll see that dip
in fiscal year 2020 fiscal year 21 plan
is
year 2020 in the door and we continue to
receive estimate payments for tax year
21 I also with business taxes wanted to
provide you kind of a visual of the
various types of Revenue that we receive
for business
taxes so at the very top in the lightest
blue are tax notices um these could be a
result of an audit this could be a
result of a penalty um this could be a
return that we received received without
a payment we'll send you a tax notice
and tell you that you owe us money um
the blue color are returns so this is an
actual return fully filled out filed
with payment on its due date extensions
are in the green so you do have the
ability here in New Hampshire to um pay
what you owe on the due date of your
return but get an automatic seven-month
extension to actually fill out the
actual return with all of the numbers so
if you're a corporation on April 15th
you can pay us what you owe um but you
can have an additional seven months to
fill out all the various forms and
schedules and submit them to us in the
fall so that's what those extension
payments are in the green and then in
red the largest category are estimates
um businesses are generally required to
file four quarterly
estimates um throughout the year and
that is where the vast majority of our
Revenue comes from and then in the
orange below the line you will see those
are refunds that we
issue when you break down estimates our
largest revenue Source into um the
various entity types here you will see
again in the red that corporations pay
the largest uh amount of estimates so
our largest revenue source for business
taxes comes largely from
corporations um next would be
Partnerships in the green
proprietorships in the light blue blue
and very small yellow fur fiduciaries
that you can see just kind of sneaking
in there in some years so this kind of
goes back
to what my conversation about the
triangles and where we see the vast
majority of our Revenue comes in the
form of
estimates they are generally based off
of the business's prior year
performance they come in with very
little information with them um it's
just a number on a form and a payment
attached to it and then those are
largely coming from
corporations this is just the last slide
on business taxes and then I will
certainly stop for questions um this
just shows generally the split between
the business profits tax and the
business Enterprise tax um this comes
out of the caffer and can just be
helpful to see um how the two taxes kind
of inter um inter workk with each other
the bet is available as a credit against
the BPT so if you paid $100 in bet and
you have a $100 liability in BPT you
would essentially use your bet to offset
your BPT and you would make no BPT
payment um so again this just shows um
the trends of those taxes um over the
past 10 years or
so at the bottom you'll see the split um
typically we run about 60% business
profits tax 40% bet that does fluctuate
year to year but the splits are shown at
the
bottom and I am happy to pause here and
answer any
questions
he start with representative
Aly thank you uh this last chart I've
been saying for years that and been
proved wrong for years that the be BP
ratio would be varying a lot and and on
we have there for
2020 a lot uh much huge a very huge
decline in the bet but not the
BPT which is a lot smaller decline um is
that something you'd rely on or do we
need to continue to wait for those
extensions from the biggest
corporations that is a good question so
historically the split between between
the two taxes has been based on a
historic analysis right so in any given
fiscal year we're looking to the most
recently completed tax year and we're
splitting the revenue as it comes in
based on the most recently completed tax
year which is roughly two to three years
behind recently with our new Rim system
we're able to do a much more
realtime um adjustment to these revenues
or split to these revenues to reflect
the true real time split as opposed to
relying on the historical split so that
is sort of what you're starting to see
in fiscal year 20 I think and it'll
continue to be more accurate going
forward again we won't be looking to two
or three years ago we'll be looking to
split the revenue as it actually comes
in that month um and so we are working
to get better accuracy with that
data thank you that that would indicate
that we've got a much the much worse
problem with employment than with
profits of large
corporations which I think is pro is is
generally consistent with kind of what
we saw with the unemployment rate being
high but then as we talked about there
are a number of businesses that are
still very profitable in this time um
because this economic downturn is not
impacting every business exactly the
same representative
Brony yes thank you commissioner um as
you know we spent a lot of time on
Market based sourcing and single sales
Factor over the last couple of years and
uh just for the new members too uh we
rolled a dice to say let's go with
market-based
sourcing um most most States slowly but
surely are going to have been going to
Market based sourcing but that requires
us to identify businesses in other
states uh that we we can tax uh just as
they're taxing us
so I I guess we have given you a year
here now another year uh because this
doesn't really go in effect until uh the
calendar year 2022 tax taxable year
correct so so I guess my only question
is have we started to uh gear up for the
proverbial searching for these
businesses that
potentially uh would have to comply sure
that's a good question so you're right
Market based ing is taxable for taxable
periods ending on or after December 31st
of this year um so most of our taxpayers
are calendar year taxpayers and so if
they are a full calendar year then that
change essentially was effective you
know on one one of this year um we will
be looking to um identify taxpayers um
who may not be currently a taxpayer but
under mark Market based sourcing they
would be because again their customer is
here um under Coster performance we were
looking at where the service was
actually being performed so if they were
sitting in this state um then we knew
that that's where the service was being
performed so it was a little bit easier
to identify those folks um and then
going forward we'll obviously be looking
to potentially identify folks that are
not currently paying tax but would be
due to um have an obligation under
market-based sourcing uh unfortunately
we didn't know this at the time um the
global pandemic is not the ideal time to
start sending out Auditors um looking
for these businesses our audit activity
um has been reduced slightly especially
during the stay-at-home orders and now
has transition to more of a virtual
auditing um type experience for many
taxpayers um but obviously as
restrictions are lifted and folks are
able to travel more we will be
implementing um the regular plan that we
had to be identif ifying these
businesses commissioner what percentage
of the taxpayers are calendar
years I we are probably close to
90% of our taxpayers are on a calendar
year
basis again that's volume and not
dollars um obviously we have some large
taxpayers that are not on a calendar
year but um 90% of the actual taxpayers
are calendar year which which is why we
look to make those changes so anytime
we're talking to you guys about making
statutory changes we like to have it
effective at the end of the calendar
year um so it's very clean and easy for
those
taxpayers uh represented uh
janigan thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to um make sure that a Something
I'm assuming is true and that would be
that um any business that received PPP
payments or state aid of some kind all
those all those um Aid payments are
taxable under bet and
BPT in general the answer to your
question is yes we can um also talk to
the committee about the taxability of
state and federal aid when we come
before you to talk about specific
Revenue estimates that we'll be putting
out guidance this week for businesses so
that they are clear about um the
taxability of those payments but in
general the answer to your question is
yes okay thank you uh Senator
rosenwall thank you Mr chairman related
to representative Abi's question the
changes in which kinds of Corporations
have done well over the past year do you
think that will have a positive or
negative impact on what we thought we
would happen with market-based and
single sales
Factor
that's a good question I think as the
um Returns come in in March and April
and we're able to get better insight
into the specific impacts for specific
Industries we'll be able to answer that
question um more thoroughly obviously
there's probably not much of a change
for you know your big box stores um in
terms of market-based sourcing because
they're not tan they're not service
providers they're selling tangible goods
um but we can certainly look into for
those service providers what sort of
services did well under covid and will
the shift to market-based sourcing be a
net positive or net negative for the
state for those businesses you also
bring up a good point about also taking
market-based sourcing and then
transitioning that to single sales
Factor so we've been asked on numerous
occasions for the fiscal impact for
single sales Factor for the change to
single sales factor from the three
Factor apportionment to just sales and
the first thing we need to do is
understand the impact of market-based
sourcing so once we know what
market-based sourcing has done we get a
return or two under our belt we can
better predict what is going to happen
with single sales Factor but having
those two changes kind of stacked on top
of each other um it was impossible for
us to um determine what the revenue
impact for single sales Factor would be
largely due to what representative arami
um mentioned in that there are taxpayers
that were not taxpayers under cost of
performance that will be taxpayers under
market-based sourcing once we have that
data then we can do the calculation for
single sales Factor so it's kind of a
step okay I don't see any other
questions now you can go into the
historical Trends sure historic Revenue
Trends this just takes everything I
presented over fiscal year 11 to fiscal
year 20 for all of the different taxes
and just kind of puts them in one easy
place for you to reference um you can
see obviously business taxes at the top
are our largest source of Revenue
followed by the meals and rentals tax
and then tobacco and then you can see
the fluctuations year to year within
those taxes so just a nice easy way to
um see what's been happening for all of
the taxes over the past 10
years and then here this will be your
fiscal year revenues to date this is
through December from the revenue Focus
um we do include here the the anomalous
receivable um but you'll see generally
with the exception of M&R and CST which
is a little bit of a timing issue um the
taxes have been performing well even
under covid that's uh certainly not the
case for every state um in general
broad-based sales taxes and broad-based
income taxes have certainly felt more of
an impact from covid and so New
Hampshire has been slightly insulated
from that um without having those two
broad-based taxes you can also see in
the last column the amount of Revenue
that we're anticipating in the last six
months so for interest with business for
for instance with business
taxes January through June we plan to
receive
58.4% of the revenue for the year so
even though we're six months through the
year we've still received only h we've
received less than half of the revenue
the real one to know is indd in the last
six months of the year we will get
almost 75% of the revenue to date we've
only received about 25% of the revenue
and again that's just to help inform you
when you're looking at these numbers and
you see the difference from plan and you
see for instance indd is 62.8% ahead of
of plan well we still have three qus of
the year to go and so that's 68.2 may
not last through the final 3ars of or
the final half of the year as we have
three4 of percent of the revenue to come
in again this is what Mr Cain was
referencing just in terms of timing of
Revenue um and so we thought it would be
hope helpful for you to have this kind
of allinone
place that is
helpful
good um lastly I'll just mention there
are a few taxes that we administered
that I didn't cover today um those are
the Medicaid enhancement tax the nursing
facility quality assessment the railroad
tax the excavation tax the timber tax
and the Statewide education property tax
these taxes um the Medicaid enhancement
and Nursing Facility quality assessment
are taxes that um are restricted Revenue
that don't flow into the general and
education trust fund um railroad tax is
a very small tax the excavation and
Timber taxes we administer those taxes
on um behalf of the municipalities so
that is revenue um that is ultimately
paid to the municipalities but we assist
them given our um knowledge in sticks
and stones and how to properly value
those and then the State education
property tax again is assessed at a
state level but is collected and
retained at the municipal
level with one minute to spare I'm happy
to answer any
questions can the planning be any
better
one minute and four and one and a half
hours I don't there is a question from U
representa Ames followed by
representative
elme okay um yeah this is really a a
presentation question it's the anomalous
revenues U and the subtraction or
placement location of those anomalous
revenues by fiscal year and so we've got
both interest and dividends tax and
business tax affected by these to the
tune of $30 million or so and um I've
seen uh um news reports that have sort
of misunderstood the situation and they
see us booming along here in the current
fiscal
year um at a pace that in fact is $30
million lower than what they're seeing
and uh I just wonder you know what your
thoughts are about sort of um helping
people understand the the reality of
this situation not losing track of the
fact that oh you've got to subtract $30
million than good point sure so um it's
a little bit of a comparison of apples
and oranges so that 30.8 million is not
included in fiscal year 20 cash basis
Revenue it is included in fiscal year
20 um audited Revenue that's in the
cafer because it is part of the auditing
adjustment it is also included in fiscal
year 21 cash re Cash basis Revenue so
the fiscal year 21 revenue reports that
you're receiving it is included in there
because it did come in the door in
fiscal year
it was late fiscal year 20 Revenue but
it was received in fiscal year
21 when we get to the fiscal year 21
cafer it will be removed from the cash
basis and so you can look Cash basis to
cash bases you can look cafer to caffer
but when you look between Cash basis and
caffer it's apples and oranges and
that's where it can get confusing so
what what we are going to do when we
present Revenue estimates to you is
we're going to include it in fiscal year
21 Cash basis because that's how the
revenue focus is reported and that's how
the comparison to plan will work but
when we look to fiscal year 21 being the
base for which we're going to apply
percentage changes growth or decline for
fiscal years 22 23 we're going to remove
that anomaly Revenue because it is not
anticipated to continue to come in in
that way every year so we'll do fiscal
year
21 Cash basis we will remove the
anomalous receivable and then we'll Pro
apply our growth rates for fiscal year
22 and 23 and again when we come before
the committee um to do those
presentations we'll certainly spend some
more time on that um and make sure that
everyone's comfortable um but it really
comes down to the difference between
looking at a cash basis report and an
acrel or caffer report and historically
this has not been a significant um
adjustment because the amount of Revenue
that we receive in July and August that
we pull into the prior year is has been
very consistent year-to year it's just
because of this anomaly which is why
we're calling an anomalous receivable
it's just because of this this one year
with the extension with Co
that we're seeing the inconsistency year
to year okay we have two more
presentation but I have two hands up and
one question from each and if you could
say your question very quickly for a
quick response would appreciate it
represent elmy
first okay uh I'll try um there is one
thing missing from other taxes Dr
administers that I think the public does
not understand very well you are the
guarantors for the entire property tax
of the State of New Hampshire and what
that means is that you have to to check
the assessment methods of and the
budgets of all of the entities below the
state and uh see what they're um whether
they have problems with them and then
calculate the rates
for for Town County School District
water
district and send them to each town to
be used so um there's there's quite a
lot of confusion I think in in how the
property tax ends up being what it is in
a lot of people's minds and I just
wanted to point that out thank
you a great Point um we have done some
um press in the past trying to educate
folks about um our role with property
taxes and how their property tax bill
comes to be and we can certainly
continue to do that um to make sure
folks are well aware okay representative
Bry I'll be real quick uh thanks
commissioner thanks nor um when it comes
to the the school building Aid uh Debt
Service for M&R and the $5 million
transfer affordable housing
fund if I had my brothers I'd like us to
predict predict revenue on top and then
subtract those but when we compare
Revenue year to year I think it was
cleaner if we just said this is how much
room and meals revenue is and how much
rent it is before we start subtracting
to to me the bilding aid and The Debt
Service are uh billing Aid Debt Service
and the uh affordable housing fund
transfer with more spending issues than
than what we're collecting on Revenue so
I I I don't want to take up time here
but I think next week maybe Mike Kane
and uh Chris Shay can also weigh in on
this how do we want to display those
things when we start doing our Revenue
estimates I just wanted to put that on
the table for next week sure that's a
great point the other thing I would add
to that list is lchip which is right
lchip great great that comes out out of
R every month so great this is something
that's been bothering me the last couple
years revenue is my my my vote but let's
have that discussion sure
okay I want to thank uh commissioner for
a great presentation and we'll be seeing
a lot more of you especially over the
next few
weeks all right we want to move on to
the next
presenter and the next presenter is
Monica Mesa
Pella not sure I said her last name
correctly but she's the state treasurer
she joined the state treasury in in May
of
2014 serving as Deputy State Treasurer
prior to being appointed commissioner of
the treasur Monica began began her
career in public accounting and joined
the state of New Hampshire in 2000
working as a financial and compliance
Auditor in the uh in the office of
legislative budget assistance spending
the last seven years as an audit manager
moniker is a certified public accountant
and holds a
aicpa designation of Chartered Global
Management
accounts moniker is a member of the
American Institute of certified public
accountants and the New Hampshire
government Finance offices Association
Monica receives a BS and accounting and
a f and finance from
lassel University in Mexico uh Monica
you're
on uh good morning um thanks very much
uh Mr chairman um and thanks for the
opportunity to be here this
morning so I was um I was invited to uh
talk about um some important topics um
so I'll hope I can provide uh in in the
information that you're looking for and
um answer some of your questions so I
would like to share my screen um this
morning
with you I just need to um see if I can
manage
that yep got
it can you see my screen
um perfect great um I'm just going to
see if I can do
this excellent
uh very good so I will um you know again
I would like to just uh cover a few
topics and I include them in the table
of contents
um so first I would like to uh provide a
brief overview of my role and and and
the responsibilities of my office um
then I would like to talk about uh cash
flow and um and our cash res servs and
then I'll I'll discuss our uh debt
management program and Hope hope there
are questions for um there there is time
for some
questions um so first I would like to
say uh that I am a nonpartisan
constitutional officer um my office is
responsible for managing uh the state
public funds um in our debt and bond
program see if I can change the layout
here
perfect and um we also have have the
oversight of the state's unclaim
property program and I know I'm going to
be back um in about a week to uh to
speak more about that I I am also the
trustee of the figh on College s plan um
and we collaborate with the college uh
tuition s plan advisory commission for
the oversight of of that
program I'm also the co administor of
the stable New Hampshire plan which is a
savings program uh for individuals with
disabilities um for that program um I
collaborate with the governor's
Commission on disabilities director um
Chu
seya and so with regard to policy we
inform policy makers uh regarding the
financial impact of various policy
initiatives uh for example we developed
the Deb affordability study uh to
provide information for prudent um
bonding
authorizations and we do not advocate
for or against
legislation also due to my position uh
I'm um I am an ex official member of
several statutory boards and commissions
um such as the New Hampshire retirement
system business Finance Authority New
Hampshire Municipal B bom bank and
others so moving on to cash and
investment
activities um our office is responsible
for the daily administration of um
between 200 and 700 plus million in cash
although in year 19 in the beginning of
20 um we reached um about 900 million in
our cash position and we've also had the
um the custody and the management of the
1.25 billion that we uh uh from the
Caris money that we received from the
federal
government so we perform a variety of um
cash management activities we we perform
cash flow forecasting liquidity reviews
we collect and concentrate the um agency
bank deposit deposits we monitor
dispersements all the payment um payment
files and paper checks go through my
office um we respond to numerous agency
um payment inquiries and we reconcile
approximately 80 bank and investment
accounts so once we're able to um pay um
our vendors and our payroll and the
various State programs and we pay for
our banking services uh either through
direct charges or via compens stated
balance balance balance Arrangements um
especially now with the low interest
rate environment we we want to make sure
we have enough interest to pay for the
banking services um so if we have excess
liquidity we invest them in authorized
short-term Investments uh typically
money market accounts uh any interest
buring
accounts so our investment policy
dictate us to prare the value and safety
of the principle provide sufficient
liquidity for the State Financial
Financial operations and optimize the
rate of
return um so a few more points I would
like to mention um we um nearly all cash
receip by the treasury is pulled uh to
fund cash operations all taxes fees
assessments aid from the federal
government including dedicated funds are
all what we call Pool cash so funds are
segregated in the state's accounting
system for proper financial reporting
but we do not hold dedicated funds
separately except for uh approximately
50 trust in custodial accounts that we
have for that we do have um those funds
in separate
custody so with all of that um I'm
pleased to say that the state currently
has uh sufficient liquidity but um is
this the cash is not is not as robust as
it was prior to the covid-19 pandemic
so we need to continue monitor um a
revenues um we need to continue monitor
the revenues as they come in and and
also how the state uh manages these
expenditures um in order to ensure
adequate liquidity so it will all depend
of how um again how revenues continue to
come in and um you know how the expense
how the states manag and expenditures in
order for us to go back to prepandemic
levels
oh one thing I didn't
mention uh one thing I meant to mention
is um our interest earnings um
unfortunately were not anticipated to
receive some um interest earnings uh
over the next fiscal years uh due to the
low interest rate
environment so the good news is that um
we have a healthy the state has has a
healthy uh Reserve account uh we have 1
15.5 million in the revenue
stabilization account uh or the rainy
day fund so RSA 9 col 13- provides uh
the framework on how to use this fund so
subject to limitations any the Surplus
at the end of the fiscal
bium uh is transferred into this account
the maximum allowable um in the account
is 10% of unresisted general fund
revenues
of of the last fiscal year of the PRI
Anum So currently the cap is 162.5
million and again in fiscal year 20 uh
the balance um was still as 1 15.5
million which is 7% of fiscal year uh 19
general fund
revenues so transfers out of the fund
are permitted if two conditions are met
one is the budget deficit a budget
deficit needs to occur uh of for the
most recently completed B Anum and at
restrict general fund uh operation
revenues um we need to fall short of the
budgeted amount the amount to be
transferred is the lesser of the budget
deficit of the revenue
shortfall and of course this this um the
procedure for that is that the
controller will have to notify uh and
request approval of the fiscal committee
and the
governor so transfers uh other than uh
for those purposes require approval of
the governor and 2third of each
chamber so um on this Slide the last
point I would like to make is that the
rating agencies will like us to reach um
the maximum allowable balance in the
rainy day fund and that is um really to
be prepared for an economic downturn in
um you know like the one we're dealing
with uh right
now
so that brings us um to how we finished
the year fiscal year
20 um I'm including in this in this
slide I'm including a chart that comes
from the uh the last caffer and um my
intention my intention is to highlight
really the um the bottom part of this
table is the undesignated fund balance
as of June 30 2020 so this table um
is providing us with the unrestricted
revenue for the year um the
Appropriations against those against
those revenues um some lapses generated
and again um the the end result um uh in
fiscal year 20 was a negative
51.2
million um so again my intention is just
simply to highlight how we finished the
year and and um also this table shows
the um the end result of the education
trust fund um and obviously the reserves
that we have uh which is in the the
rainy day fund so um all of this is a
result of uh you know a massive effort
uh to control the pandemic um all these
efforts to stimulate the economy to
provide relief to those who needed it
along with some Cost Containment efforts
instituted by the governor uh during the
year and we still finished the year
uh with this
deficit um so because the state uh
doesn't craft a by annual budget the
state didn't have to do anything um at
this point um of the banum so then now
the challenge is going to be um again to
monitor revenues um to monitor
expenditures and um the legislature will
have to cons you know we have to work on
drafting a a a new balanced budget for
the upcoming bium and also
address a potential deficit um at the
end of the
biannual so fortunately the state has a
as as I mentioned before has a healthy
uh rainy day fund uh that could be used
to address a potential deficit uh but
something I would like to highlight
again is is importance the importance of
maintaining a um you know the reserve
account and to build a backup um in
order to respond to uh fiscal needs
timely and for future economic
downturns so moving on to debt
management so the state treasurer is
responsible for administering 1.1
billion in bonds outstanding as of June
2020 uh 741 million um is um are in
general obligation bonds that borrowing
is backed but the f faith and credit of
the state 70% of that um of that debt is
paid from unrestricted general fund
revenues and we use those Bond proceeds
uh to pay Capital Improvements and
infrastructure
projects uh the bonds are typically
issued um the material of those bonds
are 20 years and we T typically pay uh
60% of principle under in the first 10
years and uh the other 40% in the last
uh 10 years
we also have um 296 million in Turnpike
revenue bonds and those and that
Services pay from uh Turnpike re Revenue
um ter the turnpike toll
revenues uh also we have the 91 million
of Grant anticipation revenue bonds or
the garv bonds and that Deb Services
supported by the revenue we reive from
the feral Highway
Administration as of June 30 uh 2020 we
we have bonds authorized in an issued of
660 million and 234 million of that were
for geo
bonds so uh we perform a v variety of
debt management activities we monitor
compliance with the IRS and the msrb
regulations
um um we um in in you know as part of
that process we uh we um uh prepare our
voluntary and uh required uh dis Bond
disclosures uh we also track Capital
expenditures um uh in order to know how
much we need to um borrow and also uh to
um to see how if if we're spending the
bond proceeds within the time allowed
especially for tax accept uh Bond issues
and um lastly we pay um all the debt
service
so the uh the borrowing costs are
largely issued uh are largely influenced
uh by the state credit rating uh we work
closely with the rating agencies uh when
they evaluate the state's Financial
condition and the oper results uh the
rating agencies uh typically focus on uh
on key points and key aspects and um the
main ones are um the Rainy D rainy day
fund balance uh whether the state has a
balanced
budget they also look at um Medicaid
pension and post-employment benefit
liabilities and funding levels and
that's to uh to see if um if if if those
if those liabilities could um create
additional burden um fiscal burden uh to
the
state they also consider the stability
and diversity of Revenue sources and
they also appreciate legislative
flexibility to manage revenues
expenditures and
reserves so we receive uh ratings uh uh
from moodies uh fit and S&P Global um uh
moodies uh assigns the state a aa1 um
with an estable
Outlook uh fit uh gives the state uh a
doublea plus within a stable Outlook and
S&P Global um gives the state uh a
doublea um we a stable out loot so in
this couple of slides I'm including a
few quotes uh from the rating agencies
that I would like to just uh read to you
some of the positives and and a few of
the notaso positives so uh for example
Moody says that New Hampshire has a
sound economy strong governance and low
debt and pension
burden before the Corona virus induced
recession rapid economic growth um
yielded strong Revenue performance which
in turn bolstered uh the state's
available reserves and and rainy day
fund following years of narrow balances
uh New Hampshire has relatively high
wealth levels and a br a broad uh stable
tax base which has helped maintain low
Deb burden the state's robust governance
and fiscal management are likely to
provide sufficient responses to these
challenges and then not so POS they not
so positives are um New Hampshire has
the population dynamics of New Hampshire
could yield economic pressure over the
medium term in high post-employment
benefits and rise in Medicaid costs May
yield budgetary
pressures so along those those lines uh
fit has similar comments uh lower
liabilities and strong ability to
control is budget um both in terms of um
revenues and
expenditures uh New Hampshire is a
prosperous state that has shifted
rapidly from manufacturing to services
and small government and low spending
are characteristic of this
state uh S&P Global U has similar
comments uh New Hampshire has
established record op proactive
financial and budget management
including timely budget adjustments low
management overall debt burden relative
peers coupled with rapid
ammortization um the rainy day fund
Reserve levels while improved over the
past two banum but remain well below the
state's 10% maximum funding policy and
that's what I meant by uh what ra rating
agencies would like to see us increase
the levels and the rainy day
fund so overall many positive comments
uh from the rating agencies and that's
what drives um the ratings that we we we
receive and and again the borrow and the
the borrowing cost um that we that we're
able to
obtain um so the last the last page um
of my presentation ation here is I'm
including a link to some of the
Publications that we post um to our
website I'm including here the treasure
dashboard as many of you know my
predecessor created this dashboard and I
continue to update this dashboard on a
monthly basis and uh this s board
captures uh key metrics that we
track which you may find helpful we
track uh we track uh our liquidity our
bonds outstanding we also track uh the
status of our abandoned property claims
um our key debt metrics um and um our
credit rating and how we compare to
other states uh and the last uh chart in
this dashboard shows our boring cost and
um I recently updated this this table
and it shows um how we did um in our
last Bor issue uh so we obtained a yield
of 1.5 87% which is the lowest we've had
uh going back to
2009 and that concludes my presentation
I know I went uh pretty quickly but I
will be happy to answer any questions
you may have yeah Monica let me ask the
first question how does our state
compared to other states where we have
to have 10% of our funds in the rainy
day
other states I hear some of them are 5%
goals can you explain
why yeah so I I I I don't have U
particular details on on the states but
but I but certainly there are many
states that have uh uh rainy uh large
rainy day funds and um um many of the
states um receive higher better ratings
from the rating agencies um so I can
provide you some more details on that
again I I don't have I I know it goes
across the Spectrum um there are states
many states that have um um more income
sales tax uh income tax they they tend
to uh fund those levels um you know
higher level um but New Hampshire at
this point has uh you know again has
been praised uh for how we've been able
to uh fund a rainy day
fund again and the point of this is is
really to you know perhaps the same may
need to um utilize that um that tool at
the end of the fiscal bium so the R
rating agencies will like us to be able
to um you know um increase those funding
levels so we're able to uh um you know
we're able to uh respond to fiscal needs
and also uh current economic downturn
and and potential future um you know
budget pressures and and again future
economic downturns so so does it boil
down to if you're a
broad-based tax state the percentage
would be closer to 5% if you're not a
broad-based tax state then there require
10% you no I so so the so the limit is
really our limit is is is establish in
statute so again I'm not familiar with
you know the other structures in other
states but I can certainly try to um
research that for you and provide some
with some information um but I think
it's just it's just um you know the
concept of having um sufficient
reserves um in order to um you know if
if there are um and again the ability
for other states to use reserves are
different than in New Hampshire in New
Hampshire were limited to uh the results
of the bium and other places they're
able to reach into those reserves um and
so in in this day we we can't until the
the bium ends and that's when the state
can take action so again I think it's a
variety of um
um I think this different states have
different methods of how to address this
um and and again I I will I I'll try to
provide you with some more information
of how um all the states um have their
structure we have a four people with
their hands up represent
Aly yeah you want to unmute yourself
thank you
uh SNP seem particularly concerned with
us not having reached the maximum we're
only 13 million or something like that
below it which seem makes it a little
odd they're doing that but I am
wondering do other states only put the
rainy day fund on one of their their
funds on their general fund because we
only have it on the general fund
itself and not the education trust fund
which the general fund has to support if
it has
problems and um then there are
Transportation funds and and there's the
whole question of the local property tax
but that's out of
this yeah again that's a great question
I don't think I have the details um you
know how the states have this structure
um we do have we do have uh you know our
mechanism is is is part of the general
fund
um in in it really is is designed to
provide that relief for you know
potential fiscal deficit or when there
are Revenue shortfalls um but again I'll
be happy to look into to to look into
how the states um you know handle their
rainy day fund a little more um I know
um the the rating agency
um you know when when when we were
talking to them um this last fall um you
know they were pleased to know that we
have not been able to we we haven't had
the need to to touch the r fund so we
haven't really had the need to do a
short and borrowing even though we've
you know they saw that we had a a
projected um a deficit uh so again they
know that we can uh tap into that rainy
day fund to take care of that um deficit
if there is a need if we end up with a
deficit um and so so the concept of
having this Reserve fund um it is it is
very important um just like you know in
our personal lives um you know it's good
to have that Reserve um Reserve fund uh
for uh for uh any um you know
emergencies and and and and that type of
thing um so so the concept is is really
that
in um but again I'll be happy to to do
that and um so so S&P
um um like the idea that the state has
been able to increase uh the rainy day
fund and that's why they as part of what
they think is if if if the state
continues to um you know review the the
levels of rainy day fund even if they're
need to be used uh for this bium but if
the state focuses on um you know
building that back up um one of the one
of the comments that they made is that
you know they will consider a a
potential upgrade um in our rating so
it's all about how they how they see how
we're going to be able to meet and and
and respond to Future um fiscal
pressures and economic downturn so
that's really the concept is that
representative tuer has a has a question
yes you're um It's a Wonderful
presentation I'm delayed that you have
given so much time to talking about Bond
ratings and your predecessor had very
strong feelings about where he wanted to
see the state go so they would pay lower
interest and generally you know present
itself to businesses who were thinking
of moving here and so forth as a strong
economy and a strong background do you
have a goal of a particular Bond rating
and comments that you'd like to see from
will'll say S&P Global he had a very
clear picture of what he'd like to see
and I wondered whether you followed in
his
footsteps thank you for the question I
will do my best to follow his footsteps
um so really is is a um it is a it is a
team effort here um you know to be able
to
um uh to reach you know to be able to
improve our ratings it really is a an
enormous effort and uh the state has has
a the state has done a tremendous job
this year um again trying to stimulate
the economy uh providing relief to those
uh who needed it and um you know with
the cares funding how um the governor
and the various task force and some of
the legislators participated in in in
that work and how the funds were
targeted to you know to really provide
that relief to those needed and and so
with all of that is is is you know the
the goal is really to continue
stimulating this economy so we can
provide uh again the better the economy
the revenues will continue to come in
stronger um you know we wouldn't need to
be worried about adjusting our
expenditures we will be able to meet
those expenditures so it really is that
ability to continue with this overall
effort um you know one of the positives
that Hamshire has had this year is is is
is the the the tax structure how um you
know by the way the state has their
taxes is is not really focused on an
income tax or a sales taxes just the way
it was designed and that is providing
that ability to for some to perform
really well and the ones that are not
performing that well uh well at least is
those funds are being compensated so my
goal is absolutely to to keep working
and to try to communicate to the rating
agencies how we you know how the state
continues to respond to all of this
pressures and all of these um uh
challenges that um you know we have as a
state and all states have um you know
obviously that's the same challenge but
um I I have to say um this last fall
when it was my my first time uh trying
to sell bonds and and I I was um working
with a a a team of um State experts you
know uh folks from HHS folks from um uh
Retirement Systems all of us talking
together to talk about you know how the
state really is performing and how well
the state has been doing and uh it
really paid off because um the rating
agencies affirmed the rates that we had
and um and and so that is great news
some of the states were downgraded this
year because because of you know a
variety of reasons um New York and and
other places were impacted and and and
we were not and so again it was a it was
a very good story to tell and um and
it's just again it's it's just something
that we we need to continue and um okay
we have two more questions thank
you brahney followed by Senator Daniels
representative
brahney nice presentation Monica um you
know in the early years of uh me being
on ways and means I tracked the unfunded
pension liability
pretty much every year I've kind of not
done that in a while and in the old days
it was the sixth highest adjusted for
size of the
State uh and that's why it was like in
the range of five billion is what our
funded unfunded liability was then I I
was surprised to see that Moody said we
had a low pension
burden
um can you kind of reconcile that has
things gotten any better that I miss
something or I guess compared to other
states they must think we're where look
really good in this area because I know
a lot of states have big big big uh uh
dollar-wise function uh pension
liabilities but again not too long ago
even our state was ranked six in terms
of the when you adjust for the size of
of a problem so can you just address
that real
quick yes I think you um you know again
thank you for the question I think you
you you said it right I think
overall um you know the state has a um I
guess it's in a better position than
other states we do have um as I
mentioned before they do worry about the
funding levels so the especially the um
uh the post-employment benefits um that
is something that the state doesn't have
a separate trust doesn't pay as you go
bases so for those those liabilities um
the rating agencies um you know they
keep mentioning they they worry about
that but overall the state has a a low
debt burden um also they praise New
Hampshire you know again for for our
debt levels in terms of our um our
general obligation bonds we we do not
borrow as much our our our our debt is
low compared to other states um I mean
we just went out and we issued 47
million in bonds and we do it once a
year um other states um there were large
issues uh in the fall from other states
so overall again we we just uh we just
have a um a lower debt burden that
compared to other states so so and and
you're right the the U the pension
liability um is is is something that you
know the state will have to uh continue
to to work on and one of the positives
that they saw this last time is um the
retirement the Board of Trustees lower
the expect expected rate of return and
that typically is a sign that you know
when you do that um even though there
will be higher contributions in the
beginning but that is an attempt to try
to address those funding levels um uh
rather than not addressing them so so I
think that's part of that comment is is
really how the state keeps positioning
um better every time and and so again
compared to other states uh we earn a
better decision okay the last question
from Senator Daniels thank you Mr
chairman are there any benefits to New
Hampshire in building the rainy day fund
to a level higher than the threshold is
currently
said yeah that's that's a great question
it really is um you know it really is a
difficult question to answer because
um building the rainy day fund to the
highest level uh perhaps will give us a
better rating um but at the same time um
you know that is a challenge for
legislators really for policy makers um
you know do you really put all your
money into this savings account
essentially or do you really want to
spend your funds and um and and and and
programs um that are needed and and
invest in you know a variety of
communities and and all of those policy
initiatives that you know legislators
and and and perhaps the governor will
have and so that is that is a challenge
that really is a a challenge and and is
a good question uh I think it's a
balancing act um again trying to uh
maximize our savings and our reserves uh
at the same time trying to meet the
obligations of the state so I know for
example my predecessor uh used to say
directly to the rating agencies um you
know this is the challenge and and and
and the state is doing a great job
providing some Aid to municipalities and
and and providing some more you know
assistance with infrastructure and all
of those um programs that the state has
done over the last few years um but at
the same time obviously um you know
increasing the balance in the r the
levels in the ring the funds is
important it's especially again you know
in a year like this one in a time like
this one we do want to have some
reserves in order to meet those
obligations well thank you Monica for
that excellent
presentation thank you very much it is a
pleasure to be here and we'll be talking
to you
again yes yes you will thank you the
last presentation for the morning is
going to be from Mr Taylor Caswell who
was commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Business and economic
Affairs which was established by an act
of the legislature in
2017 is pointed to the role by Governor
sonunu commissioner Caswell serves as a
chief economic adviser the governor and
oversees the State Department of
Economic Development and travel and
tourism development enabling and growing
the economic
vit Vitality for residents and
employees in the state of New Hampshire
in his role Caswell has defined The
Narrative of New Hampshire as a place
where people want to live and work and
where companies can grow and thrive in
the state's unique tax and opportunity
climate in collaboration with policy
makers stakeholders and Business Leaders
he's working to update and modernize the
state broad infrastructure and community
and economic stakeholders and into a
more strategic and meaningful Network
that will be critical to sustaining and
growing New Hampshire's
economy casual experience in the private
sector includes structuring and funding
Renewable Power and affordable housing
development financing services and
government relations work for a Fortune
500 Energy company and prior to joining
the Bea he was the executive director of
the New Hampshire Community Development
Finance Authority and served as
the New England regional administrator
for the US Housing and Urban Development
a White House level appointment Mr
Cas thank you Mr chairman nice to see
everyone uh wish we were in person
obviously I think like the rest of us uh
I wanted to give you a couple of updates
um on where things stand from a business
standpoint uh give you a little bit of
update on what we've been doing over the
course of the last couple of months and
uh and have some time for some questions
at the end just briefly uh you know the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs is really sort of I think
developed over the last couple of years
now as uh Mr chairman uh recognized now
we're coming up to four years of that
and really we're becoming I think above
all else kind of a One-Stop
functionality for our business Community
but also in working with other
departments and other agencies and uh
collaborating on business expansion
efforts and initiatives of of the like
and I'm happy to talk about those at any
point but a good example of course would
be on the workforce side and the uh the
developing relationship that we've uh
really engaged in with the New Hampshire
employment services who I know you're
hearing from later today uh especially
over the course of the last couple of
months uh but we do all of the state's
business uh recruitment uh we work with
companies that want to come to New
Hampshire companies that are in New
Hampshire that seek to expand uh a lot
of the work that we do in our travel and
tourism industry side we're increasingly
using as well uh to help butus those
recruitment efforts um even talking
about Workforce recruitment uh as is is
a big issue as we just heard about with
Monica and uh and student recruitment is
another area where we've been working
with our University system and others uh
to uh to bring those students to New
Hampshire and hopefully sell them on the
idea of staying here and working here
over a period of time uh the last piece
that we also manage is the States
international relations and and trade
and Export work so we have a division at
the office of international Commerce
that does a lot of that activity and
that has actually been a reasonably um
busy space for us over the last couple
of
months over the last couple of months
through the covid response uh ba has
been really sort of put into a position
of response and working with businesses
to get them what they need we acted very
early on uh during the whole essential
business uh period of time there in
March and April of last year helping
businesses understand what the
requirements were going to be going
forward and then the governor formed the
New Hampshire uh uh economic reopening
task force with which I was the co-chair
uh with DJ B cour and the governor's
office and we've we continue to meet to
this day on a regular basis uh trying
very hard to find sort of that balance
between public health and the uh in the
ongoing uh goal of limiting transmission
and now getting people vaccinated along
with maintaining uh economic VI you know
the degree of economic Vitality that we
can uh for businesses during that time
provide jobs for people and continue to
make
investments uh as I mentioned we we did
a lot of uh technical assistance I would
say well over 10,000 individual emails
and U uh and phone calls uh and web
inquiries came into the department over
the last several months uh and we've
worked with all those businesses over
that time to get them hopefully what
they needed the other thing I wanted to
mention uh was a relationship that
really developed through this with the
uh with the Chambers of Commerce around
the state this really emerged as being a
very important relationship for us uh
and I think for for members of the
chamber Community as well in really um
being able to focus in on what were the
individual specific needs either in a
locality or in a region and provide some
resources uh in collaboration with our
department to to help businesses in
those regions um be in position to come
out of this in the strongest possible
way that they can uh we were uh we were
we utilize some of the cares act funds
to provide some resources to our
Chambers to be able to continue to play
the role that they play uh and we
arranged that in a regional uh context
which ended up being very successful and
allowed for um several things to come
from it not the least of which is as I
mentioned our relationship with
Employment Services we did a number of
virtual job fairs around the state and
those continue that were extremely
successful I'm sure George and Rich will
speak to you about later um but uh one
of the benefits that came from that was
uh on the New Hampshire employment
services job portal typically if you
were looking for a job and a lot of jobs
are listed there if you haven't seen it
you should check it out uh but they were
by town and what we find is that a lot
of people obviously want to search in a
certain region where they might live and
so we were able to work with the
employment services in the chambers to
make that small adjustment to uh to the
job portal which I think in the end has
made a pretty big difference for people
that have been looking for jobs so if
they want to look for a job in the North
Country they don't have to know each
individual community that they have to
search under they can search U you so a
small thing but I think a good example
of some of the stuff that we've been
working on in the background listen
um I I would say again I know you're
going to hear from them in terms of the
unemployment numbers uh I'm sure all of
you are very aware of how we've been on
a bit of a roller coaster in that regard
over the last couple of months uh and
I'll let them speak to that uh but in
terms of biggest impacts that we've seen
I don't think I need to tell any of you
that that's pretty clearly been in our
hospitality and in our tourism industry
uh they've really uh I think had to Bear
the burden of the double whammy of the
uh the pandemic itself and I think now
more so in the areas of um customer
confidence and
people their willingness of people to go
out uh stay in a hotel or uh or visit a
restaurant has H has been a challenge
that's faced by all uh the tourism
industry and the hospitality industry
Nationwide not just here in New
Hampshire uh but due to the importance
of that industry here it's one that
we're paying a good amount of attention
to and we work very closely with uh
their representatives and they're
members of the reopening task force and
we've made almost constant adjustments
to the guidance to be able to
accommodate different uh requests where
we can to that industry um I I I I
really want to emphasize the role that
that plays not just because of the
number of jobs that are out there um but
also obviously in terms of state revenue
and the meals and rents tax and the role
that they play in uh in that particular
line item uh but I would also say as I
mentioned earlier a big part of what
we're doing at the department here at
business and economic Affairs is the
recruitment piece and I will tell you
that no matter who we're talking to
whether it's businesses or potential
Workforce or or students or whoever
tourists or whoever it is uh one of our
biggest advantages is the fact that we
live in a beautiful state and we have a
very high quality of life and the the
messages across all of those various
audiences are increasingly consistent
and one that we really um value in terms
of being able to do the work that we
need to be doing uh with with that with
regard to that so the the the need to
continue to support the the tourism
industry is multifaceted and not extreme
not just limited to the jobs and the
revenue numbers I think it is obviously
a big part of what we have here in
Hampshire and a big part of what we
offer to all those that we need to be
able to come here um other sectors that
we have seen uh continue to do
reasonably well through this process
under the
circumstances uh manufacturing industry
uh you know we we've seen increasing
investment um and I will say I don't
know if I mentioned this earlier but um
the level of activity we have in our
recruitment team our business
recruitment team is probably as high as
I've seen it um throughout this whole
this whole period of time uh we've seen
some pretty substantial uh Investments
made in New Hampshire uh liddol in
Rochester made a substantial uh uh
investment and expansion we saw milor
Sigma in Jaffrey as well also make
recent announcements lonza and
Portsmouth is actually in uh is is
working with madna right now and they're
actually manufacturing the vaccine that
is one of the two that are approved in
the United States and are extremely uh
that they've I think re reconfigured
their entire operation to do just that
um up in up in representative Tucker NE
of the woods we just saw a purchase of
the gorm paper and tissue company there
by a new firm which we're very
encouraged to see that uh we're we've
already started working with them uh
regularly and getting them hopefully
what they need to continue to retain
those jobs and grow and uh they've got
some interesting ideas on what they can
do there and Hallelujah for that um and
the other thing I would mention as well
is the the uh you're going to I think
probably over the course of the next
year see a lot more activity around the
offshore wind industry development in
the Gulf of Maine we're working with the
federal government and with um
Massachusetts in Maine in that regard in
the Bureau of ocean ocean Energy
Management in
Washington uh it's an area that we've
been highly committed to and we see that
a great opportunity for growth not just
in the new Industries but in our
existing Industries um to be able to
find additional markets and Supply
chains that they can
supply um the um in terms of where we're
headed and uh the position that we're in
I I would Point once again as I think I
did last time we met UNH and the Cary
Institute does their regular net
migration updates and they did one in
December and again we continue to see
very very positive news on the net
migration numbers into New Hampshire we
are um the fastest growing state in that
regard in the northeastern United States
we have been now for a couple of years
and most of the growth is coming in
those key demographic areas that we've
been targeting which is uh the younger
generation I would say 25 to 35 roughly
range we are seeing some pretty pretty
decent expansion in that area and growth
and that's obviously really important to
the long-term ability to supply
Workforce as well as to keep our
communities vibrant uh access to
technology you obviously we are going to
continue to see uh a work space and a
work environment that's very different
and very similar to the one that we're
engaging in right now where there's a
lot of virtual and remote activity
that's going on presents all sorts of
new opportunities for companies and for
employees uh to uh to choose much more
to place I would say a lot more priority
on the choice of where they're going to
live that isn't necessarily tied to the
place they're going to work uh it may be
ultimately but I think that that
presents a u a pretty
substantial um opportunity you i' I've
mentioned this in a couple of other
forums but um it was I think back in the
late summer that the REI the big company
out in the west coast um had built a
whole new headquarters building I
believe in Washington state that they
were getting ready to move into but
their experience in managing a remote
Workforce was so positive uh both in
terms of uh the ability to run the
company but also in terms to recruit and
retain Workforce that they ended up
selling the building before they even
got in it um I'm not suggested that's
happening at a large scale but I do
think that it's a good example of the
type of new um uh uh Viewpoint that
we're going to see a lot of employers
have and given New Hampshire's proximity
to urban areas proximity to Quality
Workforce proximity to decent technology
uh availability
to do that remote work I think that
we're going to be in a reasonably strong
position I think I would also mention in
terms of uh opportunities uh going back
again to the tourism industry we track
things like U upcoming reservations that
have been made at different hotels in
the State uh and other I would say more
anecdotal news but uh if we are able to
have more people vaccinated as we're
expecting by late spring and early
summer we can expect a pretty
substantial tourism season I have a I
have a sneaking suspicion that there are
lots and lots of people in Boston
Hartford Providence in New York that are
just itching to get uh into the uh into
the outdoors and find some opportunities
to uh get away from the city and we want
to be in a very strong position to be
able to accommodate them at that time
and take advantage of all that I've
mentioned uh that we that we need to
with our tourism
industry the final thing uh and then
I'll I'll be quiet for a few minutes is
uh we have made a number of Investments
as you are well aware over the last
several months using the cares act funds
uh for our business community and in
fact if you count all the Main Street
relief funds the self program the gap
program and a couple of other smaller
programs uh we we provided in excess of
$500 million worth of business support
programming through the governor's
office for economic relief and Recovery
um over the past several months and I
think that that's made a very
substantial difference in the ability
for a lot of businesses to continue
operating uh we've had some ups and
downs with the federal programming
through the SBA and the the payroll
Protection Program and the economic
injury disaster Loan program both of
which are now back up and running
thankfully with some new um
administrative uh functions and with
some new priorities all of which I think
are very positive but I do think that
those Investments and the speed with
which we made them were were pretty
important enabl to helping a lot of our
industry particularly last summer really
um really weather the storm of of the
pandemic the other important piece to
really mention here and I again I know
George and Rich will probably mention
this later but the investment that we
made in the unemployment insurance trust
fund is one that's going to have a
benefit to all businesses around the
state um our the the uh the use of
around $50 million to make sure that
that trust fund remained very solvent is
going to pay off going forward in 2021
for a lot of obvious reasons but I think
the reason from my standpoint that I
that I raise it is fact that uh we're
going to be able we're going to be able
I think uh employers will be much more
willing to rehire and bring people uh
back into the workforce if they're not
having to cover the the cost that would
have been befallen them if we wouldn't
have made this investment under as you
well know under under the under law this
the state uh employers have to help
reimburse that trust fund when it gets
to a certain level and we're able to
avoid a good portion of that and make
rehiring um something that is a little
less painful for our employers as we
start to come out of this I do think
that that's an important investment that
occasionally gets overlooked uh we made
a similar investment uh with Car Act
dollars for the nonprofit Community as
well who also have to pay for their
employees into the trust fund uh we
dedicated I think as I recall about $15
million for that purpose to help give
them that SAR benefit I do think that
those are some important points to raise
here as well um I I would finally say
that if we do end up seeing some
additional stimulus from Washington over
the next couple of months and or maybe
even weeks which seems increasingly
likely based on the reports that we're
seeing uh those will be resources that
we will be able to hopefully direct
towards the long-term Investments um as
a result of the of the way that we
managed our cares act funds uh in sort
of what we'll say the first round of all
of H all of this Federal money that's
made available so with that Mr chairman
I'm happy to to pause and and entertain
any questions any of the members may
have uh thank you thank you commissioner
Cas casual
um I'll get back to it representa Aly
thank you Mr chairman um Taylor we've um
this is the revenue committees and we
need to raise the revenues for the
services of the state without which the
businesses as well as the citizens um
are going to have a very hard time here
on I'm worried about the increasing
depend
uh of on on businesses that are selling
things outside the state at a time that
we are talking about going to the single
sales factor for apportionment which
would mean that most of those businesses
that have been paying the most into
state coffers are not going to be
paying on do you have any thoughts on
the relationship between our Revenue
structure and the
mix of um businesses that we're we're
recruiting I would say that um
representative uh with regard to the
single sales Factor
issue my experience over the last couple
of years has been a lot of the companies
that we see growth in and I would say
these are in higher technology areas uh
life science Industry Advanced
manufacturing those sorts of companies
are used to a single sales Factor
environment and in fact when we are in
often in competition for a lot of these
businesses to be in New Hampshire uh we
are competing with states that have made
that transition uh and and it does put
us in the eyes of those particular
companies at a bit of a disadvantage I I
really I'm GNA have to say that it's up
to members of this these committees as
well as others uh and Dr and others on
the revenue side of things my real role
here is to continue to be able to grow
the economy and the the trajectory that
I see I would say for the most part is
that companies that are looking to take
advantage of a high Highly Educated
Workforce which is in a lot of ways one
of our major selling points are
companies that are typically um
favorable to a single sales Factor um
environment commission it means they
don't have to pay
into our services I I I I you could ask
them exactly why they like that better I
think a lot of it has to do with
consistency among other states that they
operate thank you commissioner you
covered an awful lot in your
presentation um you identified a lot of
issues a lot of good things that going
on things that we need to be uh aware of
do you have a document that you could
share with the committee that covers
these points
either in bullet forms or that there's a
lot of good information there and well
thank you Mr chairman I will definitely
get these uh these all written down and
sent over to you all right thank you do
we have any other questions to ask the
commissioner if not we've had a pretty
busy morning and uh so we'll call the
morning over but like we're going to
start exact at
1:00 with the Deputy Commissioner of the
Department of Employment Security so
enjoy your lunch and we'll see you at
one o'clock thank
you members you can remain connected and
just mute your audio and your video and
um just come back after
lunch
I'm going have get
off
for
hi representative major yes um just
wanted to let you know that I've
promoted Mr gotab to um the panelists so
he'll be here and ready to
go Mr cab if you have any questions feel
free to chime
it uh no thank you
Jennifer so
um gotler will be the first pres
presenter this
afternoon um he is uh the director of
elme um Bruce deay was the prior
director that used to speak with us on
that topic yeah and um Rich labers has
also joined us and I've promoted him to
panelist um they'll be speaking together
on the employment security topics
okay we don't have a bio on them do we
I'm sorry do we have a
bio on
them I'm sorry I don't understand do we
have a bio on oh
[Music]
um possibly not I don't think we do okay
they'll just have to tell us he's been
a uh economist working on New Hampshire
the new New Hampshire economy for a very
long time and we've we've seen him every
now and then uh he works Bas he worked
basically as a
consultant yeah but he can probably tell
you about
himself a different role this time
around I'm used to being here as a
private
Economist he's the one I was talking
about figured out the relationship
between the tobacco tax and the the
gas gasoline ta uh gasoline price yeah
the real
relationship is part of our problem with
that right
now
yeah yeah that's uh that's a interesting
I haven't looked at those numbers in a
while I know the tobacco tax had been up
for a while
um I don't know recently how it's been
people smoke in the
pandemic tobacco tax is doing real well
thanks to
Massachusetts
yes all the
mentholated cigarette smokers have come
over here I wonder whether they really
have me we were told they were going to
do it before it happened I know and
mentholated cigarettes are primarily
promoted to black and brown
neighborhoods and
females and maybe females and so I
wonder whether if you went to the
parking lots of where they sell these
you would see a difference in the
clientele I live right on the border and
the sale of methyl cigarettes really
Point Sky High once
Massachusetts stop them well I wonder
whether the targeted groups are coming
to New
Hampshire that's an interesting
question
beyond my question was also going to be
how many of them were already coming to
New
Hampshire
so well except they some somewhere the
spike has to be accounted for
it shows it my
RS it's a terrible way to make a
living it
is terrible to make a living Sy taxes
remember we could part of it people are
staying home and
smoking yeah we could always depend on
our revenue from tobacco taxes to to
slowly drop but one massachus was raised
got rid of methal right they went
quickly higher so it's one
o'clock okay one
o'clock we have two presenters from the
uh Department of Employment
Security uh Rich labors is De Deputy
Commissioner and Brian gwop director of
Economic and labor market information
Bureau and they have a whole hour to
bring us up to
speed thank you Mr chairman can you hear
me okay uh
yes all right so uh again um Richard
lers Deputy Commissioner with the New
Hampshire uh Department of Employment
Security so I'm joined today by Brian
golob who many of you um have seen
before and have heard from before and
today he's um in his current role fairly
new um um although with the experience
we've had over the last 10 months it
feels like a lot more in terms of years
um that's gone by but Brian is our
current director of our economic and
labor market information Bureau so what
we thought we would do uh for the uh
presentation today um we have some
slides that we'll be able to share I
believe they were promoted up to the
website earlier today but we'll share
our screen um you'll hear from both uh
Brian and myself mostly uh from Brian
this is really his wheelhouse um and
we'll talk about Workforce uh we'll talk
about pandemic and we'll also be able to
talk a little bit about uh what we've
been doing outside of the unemployment
program that commissioner Caswell had uh
described earlier in his presentation as
well with some of our virtual services
that we've been providing to help
employers connect with job Seekers so um
without further Ado I'll um try not to
screw up uh a screen share
here and hopefully everyone can um see
um slides good job everything looked
good okay so I'm I'm gonna be in the
driver's seat which uh means that
depending on how Mr golob has been
behaving and how well he and I have been
getting along uh will determine how much
I screw around with the presentation um
when he thinks he's on one slide and uh
I'll move him on to the next uh but um
we will uh start with a with an overview
of what we'll be what we'll be covering
then I'll provide some perspective on
some of the claim numbers uh some of the
the programs by uh Source in terms of
the dollars that we've been paying out
uh then we'll transition back to Brian
uh then we'll talk a little bit about
the trust fund and um then we'll have
some more information that Mr gotab will
be sharing and obviously look forward to
uh questions from the members um as well
so um we'll start here with our with our
overview um and I'll turn it over to
Brian terrific thank you Richard and I'm
going to apologize upfront I'm I'm
working from home I don't typically do
that I have a heating issue um and I
also have a dog that loves to bark at
the mailman or anybody that walks by the
house so unfortunately I may you may
hear him barking um so you can all hear
me yes all right terrific so uh just as
an overview um I think it's pretty clear
that the US economy is struggling right
now and because New Hampshire's a small
economy we are subject to those National
forces so we're not immune from the
larger National and Regional Trends um
so things have taken a step back in the
recent months um I said this a couple of
months ago that employment possibly
could fall in the coming months as the
pandemic surges last Friday we heard the
report or two Fridays ago we heard the
report nationally that employment
actually declined in the month of
December for the first time in seven
months and I would expect that that's
possible in New Hampshire so the short
term is going to be really difficult
certainly nationally um but the Outlook
is is reasonably weak in New Hampshire
as well for the next few months but
longer term um very bullish on the New
Hampshire forecast and most of the risk
um in the forecast is to the upside um
the national legislators passed a $900
million stimulus and that has been
important it provided additional PPP uh
loans to businesses provided an
extension of unemployment benefits a
number of other things and I believe
that will Stave off us falling back into
another recession and there's going to
be a new stimulus and that will has
caused my forecast to to improve a bit
um there's a high probability and I hate
to be I'm not pessimistic but there's a
high probability that it will be at
least 2022 in the second half of 2022
before New Hampshire recovers all of the
jobs that we've lost uh during the
pandemic New Hampshire's again downside
risk are mostly short-term and it's
related to the path of the pandemic if
we can get that under control quicker
the forecast looks better in the shorter
term but businesses like Hospitality
retail anything that uh requires a lot
of direct contact personto person
contact are going to suffer longer term
the risks are much more to the upside we
are having improving migration I know
you're going to hear from Dr Johnson
after this presentation but migration
Trends have been Improv improving for a
couple of years I think the pandemic if
there's one good thing will improve them
further and we're seeing a real increase
in Innovative and Technology Industries
in the State uh there are a lot of
challenges there are no there's no doubt
and some of the charts that I'm going to
show you will present a pretty dire
picture of what we've been through and
and really where we are right now um so
we've got some challenges coming out of
the pandemic but I firmly believe that
this is going to be better than when we
came out of the financial crisis it took
us almost a decade to get all those jobs
back we'll get the jobs back a lot
faster I think that the real issues and
and I know I I work for an organization
now that that deals with these issues
but it it's labor force it's going to be
training and retraining and reallocating
the labor from the jobs that are no
longer in demand that are really going
to be the key to getting us back to that
level of of employment that we saw pre
pandemic
and lastly um rich is going to talk
about these but we've taken actions to
keep the the unemployment trust fund
solvent a lot of States haven't aren't
solvent right now and while minimizing
the negative impacts um that higher
unemployment insurance taxes could have
on employers during uh a time when most
businesses have been financially weaken
and with that I'll turn that back over
to
Rich all right thank you Brian so
certainly uh uh an aggressive agenda for
what we're looking to address here and
just to kind of set the stage with what
we've experienced during the pandemic um
what you see here is just a review of
where we were right prior to the
pandemic and when I say right prior I
mean the week prior uh to starting to
get slammed by claims um and what we saw
during the height and where we are
currently so
um continued claims so these are the
claims the claims that individuals file
um in order to receive weekly
unemployment benefits this includes all
programs available um at the time for
each of these uh snapshots that we're
providing here so the week prior to uh
the state of emergency um and uh prior
to the um large demand for unemployment
benefits um New Hampshire we were at
about 3,900 weekly claims um take a uh
step forward to the height of the
pandemic um at the beginning of May or
at least the current height of the
pandemic we all hope right um we were at
close to
177,000 weekly claims um and now we come
to where we are today with um the claims
data for the weekending January 2nd and
you see that were just over 45,000
claims we'll be getting into more of the
detail on this in terms of sectors um
rate of recovery uh compared to the
country as a whole but I thought this
was a good um snapshot to see um and get
a a good idea of the severity of the
impact how quickly it hit and the
recovery that we've experienced in a
very short period of
time um moving on on um when we talk
about uh claims just the number of
claims we also need to talk about the
dollars paid out so we have paid out
over uh a billion and a half dollars in
unemployment benefits during the course
of the pandemic to put that into
perspective that is more than we paid
out in total during the prior decade um
and the uh the short period of time that
we've been able to get those dollars
paid out I think says a lot um of the
men and women here at the department who
have been uh working incredible hours to
make sure those benefits can get out the
door and support our communities and
support our families uh during the
during the pandemic when we look at the
breakdown of programs here in the source
of those payments I'll run through these
sources real quick so folks can get an
understanding of where the dollars are
coming coming from the first um Source
the largest source over $800 million
that's been paid out in the form of
federal uh uh pandemic unemployment
compensation or FPU payments these were
originally created by the cares act they
originally paid out in the form of a
$600 plus up payment that any individual
regardless of State program or federal
program that they would receive on top
of their regular base benefit
those went from April through the end of
July um that program um Ended as of the
end of July and now that program is back
so with the uh continuing assistance act
that was uh recently passed enacted on
December 27th those payments are back at
a lower amount they are now $300 a week
and those payments uh New Hampshire
started paying those uh for weekending
January 2nd I believe we were the first
state in New England to start getting
those new dollars out the door to
individuals um and those payments will
continue until weekending uh March 13th
unless they are further extended uh with
a a subsequent relief bill the Second
Source here is Pua that is pandemic
unemployment assistance that is a
another program created by the cares act
provides eligibility to those that would
not traditionally find them eles
eligible for unemployment benefits so
these are your self-employed these are
your gig workers so you're traditionally
non-covered employees but it also
includes those people that have been
impacted by a recognized covid related
scenario where they've had to remove
themselves from the labor force and are
now eligible for unemployment benefits
all paid out of the uh federal dollars
that have made made available to New
Hampshire so again neither of those
first two sources impact to the New
Hampshire trust fund our third Source
here uh that we've included in red
because that does impact to the New
Hampshire trust fund is State
unemployment insurance we've paid out
about
$278 million in state unemployment
insurance during the pandemic that has
come out of the trust fund we have some
slides coming up to show where the trust
fund um has been going um and where uh
we are forecasting it to go during 2021
our last two sources is here our lwa
this is lost wages assistance this was
the program created by Presidential
memorandum uh back um in uh August uh
paid benefits um in uh during September
this was all federally paid this was a
$300 add-on U that was provided by the
federal government administered through
FEMA when the $600 program first expired
so we've paid out a total of $88 million
there those those weeks um that program
has since expired the last program here
is PE this is federally paid this is
pandemic Emergency Unemployment
Compensation we've paid out $27 million
these are the benefits paid to
individuals that exhaust their 26 weeks
of state unemployment insurance so folks
first start on UI there in the red uh
for those traditional types of
employment losses more um we looking at
temporary and permanent layoffs um then
when those 26 weeks expire those folks
then move over to the federally uh
provided extension of 13 weeks which is
the PE so we would expect um as um those
impacts continue um more of those folks
are going to be transitioning onto onto
PE as uh depending on the nature of
their employment loss and um their um
prospects for
returning now move it I'll move it back
over to
Brian now I'm unmuted Thank you Rich um
this chart just shows where we've come
from and puts the pandemic related
unemployment in perspective compared to
the Great Recession my charts where I
have comparisons New Hampshire will
always be the red line Massachusetts I
use the blue line and a black line
either a dashed or solid black line for
the us and this just Compares what we've
been through in the pandemic recession
with the Great Recession which we all
thought was the worst recession we
encountered in decades um to put it into
perspective we lost about three times
the number of jobs um during the
pandemic recession and we lost them in a
period of just a few months compared to
about a year and a half in the over the
Great Recession it also shows you where
we've come back and this data stops at
November um I will tell you that our
employment estimates will be coming out
tomorrow from the Department I cannot
discuss them now um but tomorrow we'll
have new numbers but it shows where we
are in relation to our neighbors and by
the way most we're doing better than
most of most of our neighbors um but we
haven't come we didn't we fell a little
bit further than the us and we haven't
come back quite as far
so next slide and again just for
perspective this just shows what's
happened to initial unemployment claims
um during the pandemic um and just to
put put into perspective uh Rich talked
about the hard work and the and the
extra hours that people put in um I was
not one of those people but I can tell
you that the hours that people put in
trying to process these claims was just
incredible people were were working
incredible hours um and I think our
state did a great job um continued
weekly unemployment claims the ones that
are paid on a regular weekly basis um
this just shows you the trend line um we
were falling uh considerably faster than
the the US um during the earlier part of
the of the pandemic uh during the summer
you can see where where we were these
are index numbers so we can look at them
on the same scale but more recently
we've kind of flattened out and the US
has flattened out a bit as well but
we've flattened out a little bit more
so we haven't made the same progress
over the last couple of months still and
I think this is important um comparing
us to the rest of the region um this
chart shows every state and the
percentage of individuals who are
collecting one of those different forms
of unemployment compensation that Rich
talked about Pua um Regular
uip as a percentage of the preco labor
force and a lot of difficulty in
assessing actually the the labor force
numbers so I like to start with the
February numbers and show how many as
how many people are collecting
unemployment benefits in our state
compared to all the other states and
what you see is that we are better than
every other state in the Northeast and
every other state in New
England so I'll turn it back over to
Rich and he can talk a little bit about
some of the impacts on the trust fund
thank you Brian so and looking at at
trust fund impact um you'll see I'll
just um go through and include all of
the information on this slide um I think
it's important to distinguish here with
trust fund impact not only with the
experience of other states um and
experience of other New England states
but also to compare and contrast the
experience that employers have had uh
thus far are what we're projecting that
they will have through the rest of 2021
and we compare that back to the
experience of employers in the Great
Recession um so so right now um you'll
see this first bullet 18 states have
depleted their unemployment trust funds
they are currently borrowing from the
federal treasury in order to pay their
weekly unemployment benefits I believe
we have 21 states that are are lined up
in the queue so another three that are
about to join that group um and and here
in New England uh we have Connecticut
and uh Massachusetts uh that are both
borrowing uh from the uh from the um
Federal uh treasury in order to pay
their unemployment benefits as folks
remember New Hampshire did borrow back
during the Great Recession uh we
borrowed uh two times during the the
Great Recession for a total of about
million um and uh there were uh 30 to
believe 32 states uh that borrowed
during the Great Recession um so what we
what we've seen here and what have
employers have experienced and I and I
don't want to minimize the impact on
employers um by getting to the the good
news here about search charges that have
been removed um dollars that have been
infused into the trust fund um because I
I think we need to talk about the the
experience that they've had and what
they've seen in their tax rates for
unemployment compensation purposes uh
but with the onslaught of the pandemic
and how quickly it hit the immediate
impact on employers was with the loss of
what the statute refers to as the fund
balance reduction um we have set in
statute all of our solvency controls for
the unemployment trust fund um employers
leading up to the pandemic they had a
1.5%
uh fund balance reduction so that is a
uh reduction on their earned rate um to
put that into perspective a new employer
coming into New Hampshire starts with a
earned rate of
2.7% uh they pay that on the first
$144,000 in annual wages per employee
and so a
1.5% reduction on that is a significant
impact on that overall uh payment from
that employer based on the annual um
compensation to each of their employees
um the uh uh thresholds that the statute
sets for those fund balance reductions
um will work backwards on this so um the
$300 Mark when the fund is above that
that's where the statute sets the
highest reduction to employers that's
what employers had prior to the pandemic
they had had that 1.5% reduction when
the fund fell below
300 that reduction went from
1.5% to
1.0% then when the fund fell below 100
um uh sorry
$275 million that reduction went from 1%
to
0.5% and then when the fund fell below
$250 million employers went back to
neutral so they are at their earned rate
without a fund balance reduction now as
Brian had just described and you saw in
those uh charts thus far the the speed
with which the pandemic hit um we were
receiving um the same number of initial
claims per week as we had previously
been receiving in an entire year so the
impact was Swift and it was significant
um so what happened was along with that
loss of the 1 and a 12% fund balance
reduction employers also had a statutory
search charge of a half percent that was
added to their earned rate so this first
went on in the third quarter of 2020
that's calendar quarter um and it stayed
on for the fourth quarter of calendar
year
2020 now getting to the the the good
news the good part about this for
employers and where we really
differentiate ourselves from the
experiences during the Great Recession
um was that because of steps that have
been taken throughout the pandemic to
try to ease the impact on employers
we've been able to do some things that
weren't done previously um one is that
the sech charge that had been applied in
the third and fourth quarter we have
been able to to remove that for the
current quarter that we in that we are
in that is the and for most employers
that's their most expensive quarter
because again you're you're paying at
your earned rate on the first $14,000 in
annual wages paid to your
employees um and we've been able to do
that because of that $50 million that
was infused into the New Hampshire trust
fund from the federal cares act um Flex
funds that commissioner Caswell had
talked about earlier today during his
presentation so that allowed us to
remove the sear charge uh for the first
quarter um it allowed us not to ever
Implement at least to date um to not
implement the second 0.5% search charge
that is contained within statute um so
those two measures um provide a
significant amount of relief to employer
um and taken together that's about a $65
million Savings in tax payments for
employers um because of that infusion
from the uh Flex funds um that we talked
about and and finally the last bullet
here something that um often doesn't get
mentioned is that another significant
factor that's keeping employer their tax
rates lower during the pandemic as
compared to Great Recession is that all
of the benefits that we are paying out
um that those numbers that we previously
saw for the amount coming out of the
state unemployment trust fund those
would normally be charged against the
experience of employers so that would
have a negative impact on the
calculation of their rates going forward
uh because of a provision that Governor
sununu included in the original um
emergency um order that was issued back
in March emergency order five those
benefits are being direct charged to the
trust fund and those employers are not
having a negative impact on their
experience uh because of
that and with this slide we now see what
the projection uh both what the actual
experience and what the projection looks
like for the trust fund going through
2021 um this includes obviously the 50
million that has been infused and there
are a lot of assumptions that Brian and
his team make um and and trying to
forecast out the performance of the fund
the the speed and the severity of the
pandemic really make that difficult to
do um um and certainly make it almost
impossible to do much further out than
2021 with any degree of accuracy U but
what we are looking at here is that um
we're looking to stay solvent through
the end of
2021 um again those other 21 states that
are currently borrowing we are not
looking to join them right now um and
we'll continue to obviously be
monitoring this um and obviously the
impact that the extensions of programs
and federally paid benefits have on this
projection is enormous um both um with
those that uh were providing the
additional $300 uh dollar um that can
have an impact of prolonging uh the
duration of of an employment of an
unemployment claim but also on the flip
side of that uh by the um extension of
those federally paid programs with Pua
and PE EU that is preventing um a
certain percentage of those individuals
from falling back onto the state
unemployment fund so both a positive and
negative impact um on
the state trust fund and now we'll turn
it back over to
Brian sure um just getting back to where
we have where we were and where we are
now this chart I like this chart because
it's one done by an independent group uh
Moody's Analytics and and CNN business
put together a what they call a back to
normal index and it basically is looking
to track the progress that each State's
economy and the nation's economy has
made made uh during the pandemic and
progressing back to what their pre
pandemic economic activity level of
economic activity was and what you see
from this chart again New Hampshire's
the red line you see how much further
and faster we were
progressing um in recovering from the
pandemic until um relatively early in
the fall um September and October um it
since that time we've really really
taken uh a couple of steps back and when
you think about why would that be well
the one factor that's really changed um
was is the progress in the in the
pandemic in the speed the Resurgence of
the of the pandemic which has restricted
people's economic activity and it really
doesn't have um a lot to do with any
mandated restrictions it's just that
people are reluctant to do and and
engage in a lot of the economic
activities that they normally normally
would engageing even if there weren't
any restrictions we would still see
people being reluctant to engage in
their normal economic activities and we
would be seeing a similar kind of of
trend line
here um just to make that point a little
bit clear this is um the red line again
is that Moody's back to normal index and
the blue line is a an indicator that was
put together by the Dallas Federal
Reserve Bank um
one of the challenges that we have faced
during the pandemic is getting uh
information and data on a realtime basis
a lot of the data that we produce that
all government agencies federal and
state produce comes with a pretty
significant lag so I've looked at things
like um Google mobility and open table
which are done by private sector sources
um but are presented on a much more
timely basis this looks at the Dallas
fed Mobility IND looks at a number of
different measures and I don't want to
get into the weeds here but basically it
measures how mobile people are in a
state or the nation compared to how much
they moved about in prior to the
pandemic so that Mobility includes trips
to workplaces trips to for shopping um
how much time they spend away from their
home a whole host about seven or eight
uh metrics that they combined into it so
I looked at that and compared how New
Hampshire was moving about our res
residents were moving about compared to
the economic uh back to normal index and
what you see is almost a perfect
correlation there so the fact that
people are not moving about um is really
the reason why that back to normal index
isn't there so when we get the pandemic
more fully under control as vaccines
become more widely available hopefully
during the summer when almost everyone
is vaccinated everyone who wants to be
vaccinated um the economy should
definitely pick up at a much uh more
rapid
Pace this chart again data will be
coming out tomorrow but it shows the
progress in regaining private sector
jobs in New Hampshire um pre-pandemic
post pandemic or we're not post pandemic
yet unfortunately but we peaked at about
just over 600,000 private sector jobs
early in 2020 we lost over a 100,000 of
those jobs during the pandemic at one
point in the pandemic and we've regained
about half of them so we thought we were
heading for a v-shaped recovery um when
it when covid cases were at a very low
level we know there's been a Resurgence
and a concomitant U kind of flattening
out of of the jobs
recovery taking a look at where the
industries in the industries that have
been most affect and again this is
through November um and it compares the
November number of employed individuals
in New Hampshire in these industries
with the November of 2019 number and
what you see if there's one thing that
really jumps out is when you look at the
bottom four those are all industries
that have a high degree of contact in in
the industry personal contact so retail
trade with the exception of of online
shopping which uh people are moving
accelerating the the trend to online
retailing but retailing requires
face-to-face interactions with cashiers
Etc Educational Services obviously and
accommodations and Food Services
restaurants have been particularly hard
hit but also Arts entertainment
Recreation any place where people
agglomerate where they where they come
together or where the interaction
economic interaction is face to face has
been hardest hit the other end you see
real estate real estate has been booming
um part of that has to do with greater
interest of people people in um areas
with less dense populations like New
Hampshire but several Industries have
been really modestly at best affected uh
during the pandemic um and you can see
those and those all of the industries
with the exception of Health Care and
social assistance um most of those don't
require much in the way of face-to-face
contact um just comparing uh New
Hampshire and a couple of industries
that have been especially hard hit this
looks at uh Food Services and
accommodations basically a surrogate for
hospitality and you see all 50 states
but you see all the New England states
there are labeled and we're all pretty
much affected
similarly um New Hampshire's a little
bit more um has been a little bit more
affected and I attribute that to the
fact that not only do we have a tourism
related economy but we also have um a
lot of business related travel e
expenditures travel and entertainment
expenditures business related
expenditures um unlike Vermont and Maine
who don't have quite as much of that so
we get the double whammy the fact that
businesses aren't um aren't uh engaging
in the same kind of uh activities as
they have in the past and we know that
that individuals aren't um aren't dining
as much um for their personal purposes
so the combination has has done that um
another industry that's dramatically
affected and we know New Hampshire is
really the retail Mecca of New England
so this really isn't a surprise we have
very high percentage of per capita
retail expenditures and it's because so
many people come and Shop in New
Hampshire because of our no retail
General retail sales tax status so we've
seen this um seen us fall further than
other states and again we've got the two
really the the the double whammy we have
less tourism activity and Retail is a
part of tourism in New Hampshire it's a
substantial aspect of tourism in New
Hampshire and we have the general
decline in in retail activity that's
been associated with the pandemic which
has accelerated the movement to to to
online retailing so those in combination
have affected us to a greater
degree the one really interesting fact
if there's a lot of interesting facts
but um when we look at the help wanted
ads um in New Hampshire during the
pandemic
what we found is that there were um for
most of the pandemic at least as many
online job advertisements as there was
in the same month of the prior year and
this shows you Compares several months
of 200 uh 19 and 2020 so April of 2019
and April of 2020 there were more jobs
listed in
2020 um October the same situation but
when we get to DEC number we see that
that number has below what it was in
2019 and there's a a couple of reasons
why I think we see this chart one is
that there was a lot of people who
stepped out of the labor force health
issues um Child Care issues um other
care issues um and as a result of that
there was a lot of need to replace
workers even though we were shedding
some jobs at at the very same time um as
we move forward to November and December
what we're starting to see and what
we've seen in the recent past is that
the longer the pandemic goes the more
Industries are affected so um we're
starting to see fewer of the jobs um
advertised in in Industries and
occupations that normally we would see
there's also been no almost no um not
the same degree of uh of the the holiday
season hiring again because retail has
been affected so dramatically so
combination of of impacts looking at the
occupations um is interesting and these
are very broad groupings of
occupations um and how they've been
affected and some of these uh
occupations don't have a tremendous
number of of individuals in them however
healthc care is one where we do have a
very substantial employment base and
health care and that has gone um you
know there's been tremendous need for um
hiring in the healthc care Industries
throughout the pandemic um
again nursing has been a an an
occupation in demand for some time um
that didn't stop during the pandemic if
people stepped out of the labor force
and there was a need to to replace them
Etc um at the other end you see
Information Technology and Engineering
what I attribute this to is one there's
not a tremendous number of employees in
these occupations um so it's easier to
get a large percentage change but the
again the longer the pandemic goes the
more Industries get effective the other
thing I think interesting about this is
what's happening in manufacturing and
production manufacturing and production
jobs despite the fact that over a couple
of decades we've seen um a fairly
consistent decline in manufacturing
employment although we've had recent
years where it's increased there's still
strong demand because that Workforce is
for the most part is an older Workforce
you have a lot of people stepping out so
even though there may not be a lot of
net job growth there's still going to be
demand for workers and that's true in
almost every industry by the way even if
we're not adding a lot of net new jobs
the fact that so many people are going
to be leaving the labor force the issue
is not going to be job availability
there will be jobs it will be getting
people um into the occup Pati that are
in demand and getting them the training
um to do
so
um again one reason why so many job
openings is that the labor force H has
been shrinking and it's you know New
Hampshire's big challenge um has been
labor force it was the challenge that we
faced prior to the pandemic we had very
low unemployment rates and we had um a
labor force that wasn't growing like
most of the Northeast the labor forces
aren't growing as as fast as the nation
overall what has happened during the
pandemic is so many people have stepped
out of the labor force um if you look at
um filings for Social Security they're
up they're up Nationwide New Hampshire
has an older Workforce so we would
expect that we would be harder hit by
that um people who are concerned about
their health maybe it's time to step out
of labor for child care issues big
reason um I looked at the data and I
think our female labor force is down by
about
1.5% um currently um male labor force
has has come back not fully but it's
been the female labor force has been
more greatly affected so the combination
of older workers female workers where we
have a high high percentage of women in
in our labor force those factors have
combined to to hit us pretty hard in our
labor force
shrinkage um I just I mentioned earlier
that I look a lot now um for timely
indicators and this is a daily indicator
of trips to
workplaces um and it com it's an index
number that compares the percentage um
change in trips to workplaces from their
prepandemic levels so what you see is
during the early stages of the pandemic
trips to workplaces in New Hampshire and
this is done by Google Mobility um
reports so basically your cell phone
tracks you it doesn't track me because I
keep my location off so I'm not in here
um but you see trips to workplaces were
off by about half now they've
recovered and they've recovered to uh
about 20% down and that's the function
of one people who have been laid off or
are on Furlow but it's also a function
of the trend toward remote working and
that Trend isn't going to completely go
away we're going to see more people um
working remotely that has a number of
impacts and a number of implications for
um occupation and Industry employment so
we're going to see some occupations that
are not going to be as strong in demand
because of that remote work um I
mentioned that that uh it's it's not
likely to get back to full um trips to
workplaces but there's one if there is a
benefit and I don't I hate to say that
there's any benefit but maybe one thing
we can take from this is that I think
the pandemic and the trend toward remote
working will benefit our um labor force
and demographic Trends and this chart
just shows you the the states that have
had the greatest percentage increase in
their businesses that have indicated
they've stepped up or increased their
telea workking for employees and what
you see is a couple of our neighbors
we're High New Hampshire's number four
but Massachusetts is number two and
Connecticut is number five so those are
states that we often draw a lot of
people from and I think um the fact that
we separating the work that people do
from the location of the business means
that a lot of those people would prefer
to live other than in um you know maybe
a major major metropolitan area or area
that costs more so we're starting to see
anecdotally um the fact that more people
have shown an interest in purchasing
homes or living in New Hampshire so I
think it will impact our demographic
Trends positively and that's reflected
in this this chart is um both a historic
and I know again I don't want to step on
Dr Johnson's toes but I've been tracking
this for decades um shows the net
state-to-state migration in New
Hampshire you know those of us who who
have been here longer remember years
where we had almost 20,000 people move
into more people move into the state
from another state than moved out
what we saw during the Great Recession
and the immediate years after was more
net out
migration um than in migration that has
picked up again um we re resumed
positive net migration so my forecast
because of the the the desire for Less
density um the fact that there's more
remote working means that we're going to
step up see a bit of an increase in our
um domestic uh migration so just to wrap
up
um my forecast for um the next two years
in terms of employment growth again I
don't see much um job growth the first
half and could continue to see some
losses but 2021 I just up up this by the
way the new um the likelihood that
there'll be an additional stimulus I
think will uh boost um some of the the
employment numbers so this shows a
forecast of 1.3% in 2021 3 3 in 2022 and
if you work through those the math of
that it would suggest very late in 2022
or early in 2023 that we would get back
all of the jobs that we lost in the
pandemic and with that I'll stop and
turn it back to rich thank
you all right thank you I'll just stop
the share
here okay um and one other point um I
would I would like to make in um
something that commissioner aswell had
touched upon earlier with the the
collaboration that we've had with Bea
that we've expanded throughout this
pandemic has been in uh two areas that
we've had to Pivot very quickly in order
to help with that demand that Brian had
showed in his slide with employers uh
that continue to seek to hire but
obviously right now it's a it's a tough
time to make those connections uh so two
things that we've done one we created a
new micro site for a jobs portal where
individuals are able to search by region
for instance you could search by the
North Country you could search by Sea
Coast you could search by the madok
region um you can also search by
individual community and you can search
by um occupational type so you can
really have that search as broad or as
narrow as you want it started as a tool
for the long-term care industry we
quickly broaden that to include
manufacturing education and now it
includes all sectors with about 400
employers that have signed up for that
um and it's a a tool that individuals
coming into the unemployment site see on
a daily basis visually before they do
anything with their unemployment claim
um the other tool that we've um we've
launched and we've embraced has been
with virtual job fairs uh the department
prior to the pandemic we would do
anywhere from 25 to 30 in-person job
fairs most of those were big events at
community college campuses and their
gymnasiums and we Rec cover the entire
floor um we quickly changed in with a
partnership with the New Hampshire Tech
Alliance and with Bea we've done uh I
think we're now now at about 12 virtual
job fairs that we've been able to do
we've had them for uh different regions
of the state we've had them for
different sectors uh the past two weeks
we focused on healthc care we did four
healthc care virtual job fairs where we
had about 200 job Seekers um having an
interest in um Healthcare positions came
on to talk with Healthcare employers so
that's that's something we're going to
continue to do not just because we think
it's a good thing to do it's because
employers are telling us that they they
enjoy it as a way to connect with
Workforce or potential Workforce uh so
that's something we'll continue to do
and those some of the new tools that
we've um um launched to ad adapt uh to
the pandemic and continuing to try to
help um uh expand uh Workforce here in
New Hampshire um with all that being
said um thank you uh to the members of
um the the Committees for the time to
present on behalf of Brian and myself
and obviously would like to answer any
questions that you might
have well thanks again for great
presentation now do uh did you send a
copy of these slides to uh
Jennifer Yes Jennifer should have it
okay information there so those are up
uploaded on the web page now
representative major
okay all right
uh
questions representative
Bry represent Bry you're going to have
to onute
yourself you know for all of us our
fingers can't move that fast to get to
the uh button to push uh great
presentation to both of you um you
mentioned the community college system
um which is a a great community college
system uh sounds like you've been
working with them a bit U what I want to
know is is
uh your knowledge is the is are
businesses approaching them for certain
skills they aren't being taught there
that they would like to see taught there
um and I know our community college
system is pretty
Nimble um but do you have any insight on
that rich or
uh yeah in the so the the community
college system and Susan hu are are part
of all of the the conversations that we
have with business all of those are
really spearheaded by by Taylor in
organizing a team um that works with
those groups uh so we've been talking
with with employers uh throughout the
the pandemic um um the Community College
obviously is a critical component of
that because they they are the ones that
are delivering that Workforce training
um we've worked with them closely um and
you know in the decade that I've been
here with the Department uh we've always
worked closely with the community
college and with the expansion of the
job training fund that the legislature
um had implemented with the last uh
where they they increase the job
training front from 2 million to 6
million one of the uh um directives in
that expansion was that we needed to do
to more to work with individuals um
which we've been doing and most of that
training uh is delivered by the
community college system so individuals
that we have that we focused on
individuals that are enrolled in
Medicaid and Medicaid expansion for our
work now New Hampshire program under
that job training fund umbrella most of
that training is delivered by the
community college system and from what
my experience and in discussions with
employers um they are are are very um
eager to um um make the changes to
curriculum to meet the demand of the
employers that are in each of their
regions thank you thank you uh
representative
Tucker yes I was very interested in your
talking about training we and and that
uh representative AB brami's question of
course uh was in that area but on the
toring how what percentage of jobs can
people take and start working from home
or tele workking where do they get the
training how does that work uh is there
hybrid system in which people work on
site under a
mentor just it's hard for me to Envision
someone who's just been hired starting
right away from from working at home
when pandemic is when the P pandemic is
over what do you see as the model well I
don't know that there is a single model
representative Tucker um you know
businesses are implementing it
differently and a lot depends on the
type of Industry um but you're
absolutely right it is difficult to
onboard
somebody um tele via telework um so I
know that we have the answer to how each
individual business um is going to or
individual Industries are going to
handle that but I will say um that
businesses have learned a lot and that's
one of the reasons why I believe that um
teleworking is is going to not disappear
um you know they've one they've
invested uh money in doing it they've
invested um you know training in it
there's a lot of sunk costs there's
knowledge that's in involved in it plus
I think they've learned something
something about their productivity um
and the number you know how it can be
done the number of workers that will
maximize their productivity so um there
is no one model for sure but you can be
sure that it's going to increase and as
far as the numbers go um I've seen some
studies that have been done by uh
different groups um and the the numbers
that I've seen puts New Hampshire
somewhere in the upper
30% um of occupation based on
occupations that could conceivably work
from home I don't believe we'll get to
that point I would expect it would be
somewhere in the order of half of that
15% maybe um somewhere 10 to 15% maybe a
little bit higher on a on a more
permanent basis but um there's no one
model and I will say because you
represent the North Country
representative Tucker is that it puts a
uh an onus on things like um high-speed
internet the ability it it it if we
don't get that right and we don't
provide access or have access available
to to more um rural areas it adds a
disadvantage um the challenges that your
region and other regions are going to
face is that a lot a lot of the jobs
that are going to disappear that are not
going to come back ret some of the
retail jobs some of the hospitality jobs
um those people will need some sort of
re retraining and there'll be
opportunities in remote working and
whatnot so they're going to need the
training and they're going to need um
you know the have the ability to work uh
telework as well we we had adequate in
where I live in the Southern Tier of
Coos we had adequate Broadband in most
of the areas until both students K12
were working from home college students
were not going off to college but
working at home and and the parents were
trying to work at home and the there is
no incentive for the uh companies that
provide the service to add to
their Wireless or whatever it is they
have and so areas where had adequate
service now have inadequate service in
other words the service remained the
same the number of users doubled or
tripled and people on Randolph Hill
where I live many of them work different
hours get up at strange hours in the
night to do work because students are on
crowding in on the U daytime use of of
tele it's very very difficult so what
seemed adequate is not adequate now and
I hope someone's tracking that problem
because you know New Hampshire thinks
you have adequate Broadband if you have
it in your town at all and it doesn't
really talk about
quantity so boil that down into a
question no that's a comment okay I'm
done rep uh representative
alme you need to unmute yourself I I was
getting there thank you um last year we
started to to uh reach out for the first
time to the Chambers of Commerce on
which hadn't been as reaching out very
often to the legislature as a whole and
on we were trying to find out what was
going on on the ground when there
weren't when there was a lag in data and
they they had started to do a lot more
serious re out themselves to to the
businesses the smaller businesses the um
startup businesses that become large
businesses um that usually aren't
contacted and um I heard from Taylor
Caswell this morning he's he told us
that on these job fairs were in
collaboration with the
chambers and I was wondering whether you
considered that a serious link for the
future because I think that the
combination
of having those resources more
available themselves would cause the
chambers to spend more time with their
existing
businesses on and help to develop things
across New Hampshire a lot more than
we've been able to concentrating on the
mega
businesses yeah representative that's a
it's a very good point and I was glad
that commissioner Caswell brought that
up earlier today as well um you know we
we're reluctant as Brian had indicated
earlier we're reluctant to say there are
any Silver Linings in the pandemic but
certainly one of um the good
collaborations has been our increased
work that we've done with the chambers
um and again with Bea facilitating that
um the the whole concept of the regional
search feature on our new jobs portal at
NH jobs. nh.gov that was really brought
To Us by the chambers um so it's just
that's one example of the work that
we've been able to do and they were
instrumental in organizing employers and
getting employer interest in all of the
uh job fairs that we did throughout the
fall um and thus far in the winter so um
there are uh that's going to be a
collaboration I think and I hope um that
we will continue to
have and um it's really it's a great
match thank you that's
terrific representa
a oh thank you
um yeah the uh in your presentation uh
commissioner leers uh the
uh you you showed us how you've managed
to avoid U becoming in need of the
federal to borrow from the F federal
government for cover our un
unemployment claims um going forward and
uh that sounds very good and it's
amazing that you've been able to do that
thanks to the cares act I guess as much
as anything but uh what I'm wondering is
what what would be the consequence for
New
Hampshire as it has been for the 21
states that have moved to that to borrow
from federal government what what does
that entail
yeah so that that's a it's a great
question and it's a it's a complicated
series of impacts right so the the the
easiest way to simplify it is that for
every dollar that you borrow from the
feds in order to pay out benefits is a
dollar that your employers will have to
pay back to the federal government in
addition to building up your own
reserves in your trust fund currently
there's no cost associated with
borrowing or at least an immediate cost
as those are interest free dollars that
the treasury is making available to
states that is only interest free right
now until March 13th um at that point um
if unless that's changed uh those
dollars being borrowed would start to
acrew interest so they would start to
have some real expenses what we saw
during the Great Recession was the
states that had borrowed the most um so
you know the the the biggest of those
was California um California never
really paid back the funds that they
borrowed from the US Treasury um they
they bonded that debt and the reason why
they bonded that debt from the Great
Recession which they're still paying
back now as they're borrowing again from
the US Treasury um they bonded that to
avoid some of the negative impacts on
Employers in their state because of the
length of time that they had an
outstanding balance so what would happen
to New Hampshire if New Hampshire had to
start to borrow is that the longer we
have a debt outstanding to the federal
government then Employers in the state
start to lose more and more of their
reduction in their federal unemployment
taxes their Federal Unemployment
Compensation taxes separate and distinct
from their state unemployment taxes
right now Employers in the state because
New Hampshire is considered to be um in
alignment with Federal requirements um
employers get a 90% disc discount on
what they pay for their federal
unemployment taxes that's about a $200
million a year savings to New Hampshire
businesses the longer if we had to
borrow and it took us a l a longer
period of time to repay that debt then
that reduction is going to start to come
down resulting in higher taxes for New
Hampshire businesses uh for their
federal unemployment comp tax and we're
still going to be having to rebuild our
TR fund here in the state so there's
there's a lot that goes into that
calculation but some some significant
consequences for Employers in the state
when you
borrow good thank you that's very
helpful um Rick and
Brian I read an article earlier this
morning on the construction
industry especially the building uh
construction industry on home building
there's a lack of uh
workers and they're paying premiums to
get them not the entry level ones but
people have experienced are we
experiencing that in New Hampshire
too no and I I'll uh I'll start and and
Brian can come in um that's been one of
the the the contrasts that we've been
talking about right with the the the
sector impact um during the the pandemic
recession versus the great recession
whereas the Great Recession was um a
percentage wise of people claiming
unemployment much heavier within
construction and
Manufacturing um now um with the
pandemic recession the the impacts are
much um heavier on Hospitality retail
Health Care uh but you know that that
continues to be an area of demand U we
still we have uh some folks from from
the trades and from construction that
are currently filing but percentage wise
it's a much much smaller percentage than
some of those those heavier um hit
sectors like Health Care like
Hospitality like retail um Brian what do
you want to add to
that when you're talking about um uh
skilled trades people that's been an
issue for some time um You Know Rich
mentioned the Great Recession we saw a
lot of people exit the uh the
construction industry because
construction was down for so long um it
has been an area that um has not
attracted a lot of young workers over
the last decade or more um you know
we've come through a period of time for
decades where we've told every young
person that they needed a four-year
college degree in order to earn a decent
living and that was a mistake um and and
so it's been a struggle to get skilled
trades people for some time I think that
will probably continue there's greater
efforts at the secondary school level to
um to entice workers with apprenticeship
programs and work different kinds of
programs to get people interested I
talked to people in the industry and
they complain about it they have
complained about it um and they've got
campaigns in order to get more young
people interested in the in the field
but there is right now a seasonal
slowdown Rich mentions we've seen an
uptick um that's particularly in heavy
construction you know things like roads
and bridges and streets and sewer
systems um that inevitably slows down
this time of year so we're seeing kind
of an uptick in um you know in claims in
those
areas I'm talking about the building
industry for homes and that's I I know I
I know it's a small percentage but it's
a catalyst for our economy it is
without the housing availability we're
not going to get people here to grow our
economy right housing is a big issue
Supply um I had some charts that I
didn't include in this presentation
because I didn't want to get too much
into housing but there's two issues um
you know there's a increase in demand
part of that's pandemic related again
Silver Lining if there is such a thing
um but it it's also um a supply issue
the supply has gone down consistently
for almost a decade so months uh you
know months to absorb the supply has
gone down I have a chart that shows that
so you've got a combination of both an
increase in demand
surprisingly um during a pandemic uh but
interest rates are very low so there's
there's demand for that and the supply
has declined is has been declining I
think that eventually it will get a
little bit better we have a lot again we
have a lot an older population and a lot
of those individuals are aging in place
they're staying in their homes but at a
certain point those individuals tend to
move to more um assisted living
facilities or group kinds of of settings
and that frees up some houses so I think
probably over the next decade it'll be a
little bit longer we'll start seeing
more Supply come on and that will help
ease some of it but the bottom line is
we've got a lot of restrictions that are
preventing and it it varies by Community
some communities are very good and have
allowed a lot and their communities that
are seeing their demographics improve
and I happen to live in one of those
communities over where the you know the
population has grown um the population
of young people has grown and part of it
has to do with the willingness to allow
certain types of
housing all right um we have two more
hands representative
ralo you um a quick question about the
uh
administrative contribution rate and
where does that go I noticed that one up
as
well yes representative so the the the
administrative contribution rate so that
is currently set at
0.4% so that was essentially doubled as
a part of that reform to the job
training fund uh so uh the job training
fund went from $2 million a year that
was uh paid by New Hampshire employers
but diverted from going into the trust
fund and instead goes into job training
fund now at that 6 million and in order
to fund that additional increase the
administrative contribution rate um was
increased from 0.2 to 0.4 uh so right
now the dollars generated by that uh
they first go towards funding that $6
million annually that goes into the job
training fund then uh they uh then
Supply New Hampshire employment security
with administrative funding that which
the federal government does not fund us
to keep our our 12 New Hampshire Works
offices open um we would have about six
of those offices if we relied entirely
on our federal uh Workforce dollars
those AC dollars allow us to keep all 12
of those offices open New Hampshire
employment security is held harmless at
the amount of administrative
contribution funding that we received
when the rate was 0.2 we received the
same amount now even though the rate was
increased to 04 so where does the rest
of that go it then goes back into the
trust fund so the the additional six the
additional four million goes uh to bring
that job training fund up to six million
Employment Security is held harmless at
what we had received for administrative
funding in order to um Shore up that
deficit from the Federal Grant and then
the rest of it goes into the trust fund
to try to reduce the impact on employer
tax rates okay the last question is from
representative
Alman thanks uh this is a followup on
that question of Housing and we've
got there are three people who know how
to repair Wells within a 100 miles of
me on they are almost impossible to
get especially after the drought this
last summer
um and nobody else knows how to do that
you can't you you you don't learn it
growing up uh but it's just we don't
have Carpenters we don't have plumbers
on Carpenters can learn on the job
usually plumbers electricians can't and
you have to go a great distance from on
the west of the state for instance to go
to a place where you can get the
training that you need on I'm just this
has been a hobby horse of mine for some
time to the Bia but um I just do you
have any kind of data on on these kinds
of jobs in different regions of the
state is it I I had assumed this was a
regional problem but you're talking
about it as if it's a Statewide problem
we do have data in terms of um job
listings or both job listings that we
have but also online job listings um by
community at the community level so we
can see um by any particular occupation
what the demand is in a town or a county
or a labor market area so we do have
some idea um of that but that you know
that's
probably uh in the overall context a
relative atively small number of
individuals um and you know I don't know
what the hiring practices of
organizations that hire those folks
whether they're used to using online job
ads or whatnot so combination of factors
and and I just
subcontract these jobs that I was just
talking about uh from a construction
firm which is basically constructing the
building and then they subcontract to
the drainage expert can't find one of
those either I a small
complex and um so they probably don't
appear in your files would be the yeah
okay I'm I'm gonna wrap this up and want
to thank both of Richard lers and Brian
gotot for an ex an excellent
presentation and we hope to hear from
you
again great thank you very
much yeah thank you all now we'll go to
our last presentation for the
day which is from uh Kenneth and Johnson
who's a senior de demographer at the
Casey School of public policy and
professor of Sociology at the University
of New Hampshire he's a nationally
recognized expert on us demographic
Trends his research exam is National and
Regional population
redistribution rural and urban demograph
Ric change the growing racial diversity
of the United
States and the implications of
demographic change for Public Policy Dr
Johnson has published a book on more
than 250 articles reports and
papers his peer review Publications have
appeared in leading academic journ
journals he's also sought after for his
expertise and ability to explain
demographic information to a broad
audience both by policy groups and by
the media his research has been funded
by grants from the National Institute of
Health National Science Foundation US
Department of Agriculture and US Forest
Service and the National Aeronautics and
Space Administration Dr Johnson is an
Andrew con F fellow which is the
country's most prestigious Fellowship to
Advan research in the social sciences in
Humanities good to see you again Dr
Johnson the floor is yours thank you
very much nice to talk to you again even
if it is remotely like this um I'd like
to uh show you a slide presentation so
I'm gonna put that up right
now
okay so again you introduced me already
again I'm just acknowledging the groups
who have funded my research including
the University of New Hampshire's
experiment station and the charitable
foundation and the health
endowment um I want to talk to you today
about New Hampshire's demographic Trends
I want to emphasize two points though
number one demographic data the
demographic data I'll present here
doesn't include the period of the
pandemic that data is not available yet
from the Census Bureau or from anybody
else for
demography and ALS Al there's no data in
this presentation from the 2020 census
which has not no data from the 2020
census has yet been released so we don't
have access to that data yet either um
it should the First Data from the 2020
census will be released probably by
March 1 and that'll be the
reapportionment files uh which will be
of great interest to everybody in New
Hampshire and elsewhere in the United
States but let me talk to you about the
data that we do have and uh this first
slide is the only one that goes all the
way through July of
2020 and it shows population change this
one shows population change in New
Hampshire and the rest of New England
and you can see here that the population
estimates suggests that New Hampshire's
population gain in each of the last
three years have been larger than
population gains in any other state in
New England and actually in the
Northeast um these are percentage gains
though I caution to to remind you these
are not number gains because of of
course Massachusetts and Connecticut are
much bigger States than New Hampshire is
but in any event in the Northeast New
Hampshire is actually doing reasonably
well in terms of population change in
the last few years although the growth
in the Northeast and in New Hampshire is
considerably slower than it is in other
parts of the country in the South and
the
West this begins to give you some idea
and I'll come back to this theme at a
number of points these SE are the
different drivers of population change
the blue bar here is how much population
change there was in absolute numbers
annually the red bar is the amount of
natural increase natural increase is the
difference between the number of births
and the number of deaths in New
Hampshire or elsewhere in the United
States and then the green bar is
migration and you can see if you look
back over the last several decades that
a lot of New Hampshire's growth is a
function of net migration that is people
moving into the state more people moving
into the state than leave as you can see
as we get closer to the more recent
periods migration to New Hampshire has
slowed and for a while natural increase
the red bar again in the 1990s and the
2000s actually contributed slightly more
to the population growth since 2010
natural increase in New Hampshire has
slowed down quite a bit there are and in
the last couple of years actually more
people are dying in New Hampshire than
being born so all the growth in New
Hampshire in the last few years as I'll
show you on this next slide have come
from migration so if New Hampshire is
going to grow it's going to grow through
migration because the excess of births
over deaths which used to help fuel the
growth in New Hampshire no longer
exists and obviously the covid epidemic
is not going to make things any better
in this
regard so again this shows you for the
most recent periods and and I tried to
characterize the periods here in
relation to the Great Recession so you
can see in 2010 to 2012 the great
recession's effect was pretty
substantial in New Hampshire and just as
Brian mentioned in the earlier talk
there was net outmigration of domestic
migrants the orange bar here is
immigrants the gray bar is domestic
migration people moving to New Hampshire
from other us
destinations as the effect of the
recession began to WAN and particularly
in the last several years migration
particularly domestic migration has been
an important factor in the growth of New
Hampshire in other words domestic
migration has again started to
contribute to the growth in the
state just I want I want to give you a
feeling for how these things change
because when you look at this net change
for example in migration it's 30,000
people that's not very much in a state
of 1 Point almost four million people
but just to understand what's happening
this is the number of people that moved
into New Hampshire in that period that
fiveyear period about 245,000 people
moved into New Hampshire
214,000 left for a net change of 30,000
what I want you to appreciate here is
how much movement there was to produce
this relatively modest change so the the
actual people in New Hampshire a lot of
them changed as a result of people
moving in and out you can also see
immigration and births and deaths but
you can see the powerful influence of
migration on change in the size of the
population and in the actual people who
are in the state this is natural
increase this is the difference between
births and deaths over the last 50 years
and you can see New Hampshire used to
have a fairly significantly higher
number of births than deaths but in the
period since the Great Recession that's
dramatically changed and those Chang are
driven by changes in the age structure
the New Hampshire population is getting
older and that means that there are more
people at risk of mortality and there
are also fewer women in their
childbearing years to produce children
the birth rates have also diminished
both in New Hampshire and in the United
States generally and so the result has
been that in the last three or four
years New Hampshire actually has had
more people die in it than be born and
you can imagine now what's going to
happen in 2020 when the effect of the co
mortality wave starts to hit New
Hampshire and many demographers
including me also expect that in 2021
this year there's going to be a
significant decline in the number of
births because as you would know of
course you understand nine months have
to elapse between a conception and a
birth so as the pandemic began to be a
bigger factor it's my expectation as
well as that of lot of other
demographers that probably the number of
people who decided to have children
diminished that it wasn't a good time to
be having children and so I'm expecting
the number of births to diminish next
year uh this year as well as the number
of deaths to remain high because of
Co so in other words New Hampshire's
future and its labor market mostly
depend on
migration so this is demestic migration
this is the number of people moving to
New Hampshire from other states in each
year from 2005 before the Great
Recession through the period of the
Great Recession and then on into the
recovery from the Great Recession and
notice in particular the green bars are
net migration so the blue bar is how
many people moved into the state the red
bar is how many people move out of the
state and nor recently we've got had
significantly more people moving into
the state than out just as we did before
the recession and if you could see the
70s and the 80s and the 90s the blue bar
would be remark markably High compared
to the Red Bar you can see the exception
to that was during the Great Recession
when more people actually left New
Hampshire then came to it mostly because
the number of people coming to New
Hampshire diminished you notice that the
red bars don't change very much here
what changes is the height of the blue
bar which is the number of people coming
to New Hampshire so what's happened
recently as the number of people coming
to New Hampshire has increased
again
where do the de the migrants come to New
Hampshire from the left Circle shows you
where people moving to New Hampshire
come from and as you probably aren't
surprised the largest single source of
Migrant migrants to New Hampshire are
from Massachusetts uh almost 23% of the
people living in Massachusetts were act
or I'm sorry living in New Hampshire
were actually born in
Massachusetts uh including I suspect
some of you on the right hand side is
where people go to when they leave New
Hampshire and you can see again that
Massachusetts is a big attractor but
notice how much more attractive the
south is and a lot of this is retirement
migration to the South so just a feeling
for where people are coming to and going
from this represents about 53,000 in
migrants to New Hampshire this
represents about 42,000 out migrants and
then I haven't shown in this graph but
another 6,400 people moved into New
Hampshire from abroad they came either
as immigrants
or they came as people coming back to
New Hampshire who'd been away and at
school or working in jobs
overseas now New
Hampshire un is unusual in the sense
that much more of its population is a
result of domestic migration others
these are people who live in New
Hampshire who were not born in New
Hampshire these are immigrants to New
Hampshire these are people living in New
Hampshire who were born in New Hampshire
and you can see how New Hampshire is
different either than massachus
Massachusetts and the rest of New
England or than the United States more
generally in that it has a much smaller
proportion of its population born in the
state and a much higher proportion of
its population born in another US state
about 42% of New Hampshire's whole
population was born in another
state if you look at the age structure
of the population this not may not be
too
surprising among children more of them
were born in New Hampshire but as soon
as you get into the adult population you
can see that a substantially larger
proportion of the people living in New
Hampshire were born in other states and
again I emphasize this to you because I
want you to see how important migration
is to New Hampshire particularly
domestic migration from other us
destinations and it's important in more
ways than one New Hampshire benefits
from migration into the state in terms
of intellectual Capital that is the
population moving into New Hampshire
tends to be better educated and you can
see that here in the orange bar which is
the number of people who were born in
another state who are college graduates
nor that note that New Hampshire gains
from that as well as it does from
foreign born population in New Hampshire
but that's just a small part of the
population compared to the number of
people born in the other state both of
those groups are more likely to be
college educated than the people
residing in new who were born in New
Hampshire at some college level you can
see the patterns a little bit different
and among less well educated people the
New Hampshire residents tend to be a
larger proportion than the college than
the people moving from other
places even during the recession these
are the migration streams of different
education levels into and out of New
Hampshire note that the New Hampshire
still gained from from migration this is
the number of people during the
recession who moved out of New Hampshire
who were college graduates annually on
an average these are the number of
people who moved in you can see that in
a more recent period we have
substantially more people moving in than
moving out who are well educated so New
Hampshire benefits from an inflow of
migrants it gains educated people from
that these are age specific migration
pattern showing you how different age
groups move into and out of New
Hampshire these are older data from the
1990s and the 2000s I'll show you some
new data in just a minute but notice
that New Hampshire tends to gain people
in their 30s and 40s and their children
who would come with them it has in some
decades it's had modest losses of people
in their 20s and then it has modest
gains in of older adults into the state
as well so it's not as if everybody
retires and moves to New Hampshire in
fact New Hampshire tends to get more
people in their 30s and 40s and again
children with
them this is the most recent data we
have for I showed you two periods 2010
to 14 when the states still recovering
from the Great Recession and 15 to 19
which is the newest data available and
again you can see this inflow of people
in their 30s together with their
children the most recent data show an
influx of people in their 20s as well
again these are sample estimate data
they're good samples they're from the
ACs a big uh survey that the uh Census
Bureau does but they are sample data
they're not like having the census and
so you can see that many of the trends
that we see in the longer term data are
continuing although it looks like we may
be getting more young adults right
now just to give you a feeling of New
Hampshire compared to another state this
is Massachusetts Massachusetts tends to
gain people in their 20s and again think
of all the universities and colleges and
Massachusetts who would
attract uh people to them young people
to them but Massachusetts tends to lose
population in their 30s and 40s where
New Hampshire gains those people and
again given the big flow between New
Hampshire and Massachusetts you can see
how this would play out so here's New
Hampshire gaining people in their 30s
and 40s and their children whereas
Massachusetts is losing these young
adults and some children and then I mean
is gaining I'm sorry people in their 20s
but it's losing people in all these
other age
groups just to give you one more idea of
this and why it might be relevant in New
Hampshire this is the number of children
born in New Hampshire the blue bar and
this is the number of children who begin
the first grade six years later in New
Hampshire so you'll notice in every
year although it slowed during the
recession but picked up a little bit
near the end and every year more people
begin the first grade more children
began the first grade in New Hampshire
than were born in New Hampshire six
years earlier now this happens because
those people who are moving into New
Hampshire those people in their 30s and
40s are bringing their children with
them and as a result New Hampshire gains
children in its school system because of
that influx of
people now as you well know demographic
change varies across New Hampshire this
just shows you for the 2010 to
209 period on the right and for 2000
to20 it shows the relative annual growth
rate in different parts of the state so
Reds and pinks are places that lost
population greens and blues particularly
Blues are places that gain population uh
during the 10 the nine-year period from
2010 to 19 given our census estimates so
you can see that the general trend is
the same usually it's the northern part
of the
state which has the smaller population
gains or actually loses populations and
then in the southern part of the state
especially just beyond the Boston uh
metropolitan area Edge are areas that
are gaining
population so even though there's less
population gain 2010 to 2019 generally
the patterns of how that gain occurs are
very similar let me give you an example
this is for three different counties in
New Hampshire here's Coos County Carrol
County a big recreational County in the
middle part of the state and then
Hillsboro County and you can see that in
Hillsboro County population growth has
occurred between 2010 and 2019 both
because of natural increase the Red Bar
Bar and because of migration into the
state mostly immigration into this uh
area but not all of it Carroll County
the recreational County actually has
more people die than be born in it
because it attracts
migrants who are attracted by its
amenities and opportunities for
recreation and many of them had owned
second homes and moved to them
eventually and there may be more of that
going on because of the covid epidemic
people who are it appears that people
who have second homes are using them
more now than they have in the past so
that migration into Carol County is
enough to offset the natural decrease
Coos County has a substantial amount of
natural decrease so considerably more
deaths than birs and a very modest
amount of migration into the county
which partially but can't totally offset
this natural increase to produce
population decline so even within the
state there's quite a bit of variation
and then this is just Hillsboro County
and i' broken it up into the city of
Manchester the city of NASA and then the
rest of the county which I'm calling
Suburban Hillsboro County and you can
see even at this narrower
view in man both Manchester and NASA
what growth there is is coming from
natural increase it's become because
there are more births and deaths in the
city Manchester has lost po has lost
population throughout migration NASA is
just about holding even in contrast in
the Suburban part of the county there's
natural increase but there's also a
significant amount of migration into
these areas which is fueling population
increase now I emphasize again to you
these are estimates we won't know some
of these numbers for sure until the 2020
census um and so it's just to give you a
feel for how much variability there is
in demographic change around the state
both from County to County but even
within a county between place to place
now these patterns that you see with the
cities gaining population mostly through
natural increase and the suburban area
is experiencing both migration and
natural increase these same patterns
would play out in almost any
Metropolitan county in the United States
if you went to you know Boston metro
area if you went to Denver or Chicago
you would see similar patterns of the
Cities growing mostly for natural
increase and the suburbs growing a lot
from that
migration you've heard already about how
New Hampshire is aging let's let me just
show you the latest data that we have on
that here's the demographic change in
New Hampshire by age so these are 0 to9
year olds 10 to 19 year olds 60 to 69
year olds this is the
1990s this is the 2ou I'm sorry this is
the 1990s the blue this is the 2000s
this is the period since 2010 and you
can see that New Hampshire has tended to
lose younger people because of age much
of it because of aging and gain people
in these older age groups much of this
is the Aging of the baby boom New
Hampshire has a very large Baby Boom age
population and as they've aged from the
90s to the 2000s to the
2010s the population is essentially
shifting this way as a lot of New
Hampshire's population ages in place so
the population is Aging in the state and
there are the number of children in the
the state is
diminishing this is a population pyramid
that demographers use to look at how the
population is changing these are men in
blue and women in red these are the
youngest this is
1990 so this is the youngest age group z
to four year olds in 1990 these babies
would have been born in 1986 to
90 you might see your children or your
grandchildren in this group up here is
in their 30s in 1990 30 to 34 year olds
is the very heart of the baby boom the
largest cohorts of the baby boom are
right here so that bulge you see right
there with the smaller bulges on either
side of it that's the baby boom and you
could look in any state in the United
States you could look at the United
States data as a whole in 1990 you would
see this big bulge there's the baby boom
here's where the baby boom should have
had their children but they delayed
having children that is where the baby
boom mothers the mothers of the baby
boom mostly had their babies when they
were 20 or 21 or 22 in their early 20s
the Baby Boomers themselves didn't have
their children until they were a little
bit older this Gap is where these
mothers these women should have had
their children but here they are instead
having their children further down so
this Notch is partially a relate a
function of the delayed fertility among
the baby boom Okay so this is
1990 average age of the New Hampshire's
population the median age was 32.8 these
red bars represent the working ages from
18 to 65 now I'm going to move
forward this is 2000 see the baby boom
moving up and that Notch that we
saw uh is now the 20 to 24 year olds in
2000 one of the big worries in New
Hampshire was that there weren't very
many young people and there was a lot of
concern about why that was one school of
thought was that those that lots of
young people were leaving New Hampshire
in fact what happened is they were
really never born because of the delay
in the mothers of the CH of the baby
boom in having their
children so this is 19 this is 200000
the median age has gone up here's
2010 so now everybody's 10 years older
so those baby boomers are now in their
50s or right and here are
that that little notched group that we
had talked about before born in the 70
early 70s or mid '70s and then this was
the babies who were just born in 1990
now they're in their
20s and then finally here's the most
recent data for 29 20 2019 you can see
the big bulges now of older adults in
New Hampshire this is the baby boom
aging into their older age groups and
when Brian was saying before or you've
heard in other places that the older
population in New Hampshire is going to
gain very rapidly or grow very rapidly
here it is these are people who are
aging into the older age groups
including the baby that heart of the
baby boom which in 2019 is now in their
60s and the cohorts above them who are
baby boomers too and are still big
cohorts but you can see these very large
cohorts and then behind them are much
smaller cohorts so this is of the issues
that New Hampshire CH faces is this
aging of its population the median age
is now up to
43 now this aging is is varies across
the state these are population
projections I didn't make these
population projections but somebody else
did for the New Hampshire office of
strategic initiatives and what it's
showing you is different age groups
these are 0 to 19 year olds 20 to 39
year olds 40 to 64 year olds the older
part of the labor force and then these
are older
adults this is their age distribution
through 2020 and these are EST these are
the New Hampshire offic of strategic
initiatives estimates of what the
population will look like in the next
this is 2030 2035 and so forth you can
see again the Aging of the
population the number of people in their
40s to 60s stays relatively stable but
the older population inre inrees in size
so this is just one estimate it it's
subject to considerable error we
whenever we make projections there's
always a chance of mistakes or errors in
changes in situations for example this
doesn't take into account the
pandemic the population distribution by
age in New Hampshire varies as well some
parts of New Hampshire have larger
proportions of children so the these
gold towns or tracks are are places
where there are lots of
children a lot and not only are there
lots of children as you can see over
here because it's showing how many
children and where they are but also the
proportion of children is high so these
are the kind of areas that might be
concerned about things like should we
build a new school should we add a wing
to the school so we'll have room for
more
children in other parts of the state
where the child population is relatively
small the issue
for the schools might be different
should we consol do we have to
consolidate can we are we going to have
to close one of our schools because we
don't have room we don't have enough
children anymore so again even in a
state like New Hampshire which is small
in size there's considerable variability
in the age structure of the population
this is the working age population again
you can see the large concentrations of
people in the working ages down here and
then in other parts of the St State a
smaller proportion of the population in
the labor force age group and again
here's the actual numbers these are
percentages so this is giving you a
feeling of the relative size this is the
absolute numbers so you can see the
concentration of working age population
here for example this then is the older
population and again you can see that
proportionally the population tends to
be older in the northern part of the
state than it does in the southern part
of the state but the vast majority of
older adults are in the southern part of
the
state
so again I I just want you to see that
there's more than one way to think about
these data the percentage distributions
tell you one thing where are seniors a
large part of the population but another
question is where are there a lot of
seniors and you can see that that's more
likely to be in the southern part of the
state where more of the population
is in terms of racial and ethnic
diversity New Hampshire remains far less
diverse than the rest of the country but
it's growing in a diversity just like
the rest of the country this is the
racial diversity of the United States in
each County and the measure here is if
you ran into another random individual
in this County what are the chances that
they're of the same race and ethnicity
as you or of A different race in
ethnicity in the oranges and reds are
places where the chances that somebody
you run into in the street is going to
be different than you is higher in the
areas that are Blues especially the
darker Blues are places where if you run
into somebody on the street they're
likely to be the same race and ethnicity
as you so you can see the remarkable
diversity within the United States but
you can also see how it varies from
place to place here's a closeup of New
England just so you can see New England
and again you can see the level of
diversity in New England is far lower
than in other parts of the state I know
this is is no news to you but I just
wanted you to see it graphically but
even though that's the case in New
Hampshire about 10% of the population
10.2% of the population is minority but
here's the key thing I want you to see
in this most of the growth in New
Hampshire's population 93% of the growth
in the population of New Hampshire since
2010 has been of minority people the
minority PE population
is growing more rapidly than the white
population is so even though it
represents a very Modest part of the
state it's a growing part of the
state and if you want to look at what
parts of the population this is
happening in here's the white population
this is non-hispanic Whites Whites who
are not Hispanic here's the white
population and then here is the uh
minority population so you can see that
the number of white children in New
Hampshire declined quite tremend
dramatically since 2000 the number of
minority children increased modestly not
enough to offset the loss of children
who are white in the in the working age
or adult age groups the minority
population in absolute numbers grew more
than the minority population and then
among seniors almost all the growth of
the older population in New Hampshire is
of whites So within the age structure
quite a bit of
variability one thing to remember about
the age structure of New Hampshire and
this is true in every US
state the US population has becoming
more diverse from youngest to oldest the
most diverse part of the population of
the United States are the babies that
were born last year the least diverse
part of the United States population are
the oldest adults and you can see that
in New
Hampshire about 10% of the population of
New Hampshire 10.2% is minority but
15.7% of the child population is
minority and about 9% of the adult
population so you can see the diversity
coming from the bottom up in New
Hampshire's population just like it is
in every other US
state so the first institutions that
have to deal with a growingly diverse
population are the hospitals where the
babies are born and then the school
systems which have to deal with an
increasingly diverse population
now as you're well aware diversity
varies dramatically across New Hampshire
there are parts of New Hampshire which
have very small minority populations and
I show you here the whole minority
population of all ages which again is
10.2% at the state average and then this
is the child population and you can see
even in places where the population is
not very diverse it's the child
population that's the most diverse
if we focus in more this is the the uh
NASA to conquered Corridor you can see
the diversity of the population is
greater here Hillsboro County has the
most diverse population of any of the of
the New Hampshire counties and then you
can see again this is the whole
population this is the minority
population again you can see places in
these count in this Corridor where there
are fairly substantial minority
population ations particularly of
children this is a closeup now of just
Manchester and you can see that there
are considerable neighborhoods in New
hampsh in in Manchester which have
minority populations of children of 40
or more
percent so even in a state which isn't
very diverse there are places where
there are quite diverse populations in
New Hampshire and it's primarily
children where the population is going
to be the most
diverse let me give you just one more
example this is the minority population
in Manchester and I picked out three
census tracks which are the small areas
that the Census Bureau measures data for
and I wanted you to see the difference
between this track just on the edge of
Manchester which is virtually all
non-hispanic white and then this
track which is strikingly diverse this
is of the whole population not just
children its child population is over
40% minority so you can see whether
you're talking about the state as a
whole about the region or about the
individual town There's dramatic
variation in the amount of diversity in
this state and I think that's important
for you to recognize as you address all
the many policy issues that you have to
deal with so even in a state like New
Hampshire which is not particularly
diverse there is remark there are
remarkable pockets of diversity within
the state
and it's not just on
race this is income and uh education
this is all of New England just so you
could see how New Hampshire compares to
other places you can see it has a
relatively High median income compared
to the rest of uh New England and also a
particularly in the southern part of the
state a particularly well-educated
population here's a closeup of the
census tracks in New Hampshire and so
you can see that the diversity about 37%
of the population adult population over
the age of 25 of New Hampshire have
college degrees or more but you can see
it varies a lot from in parts of the
state the median family income in New
Hampshire is about
95,000 but you can see the variation in
median family income as well this is
again just I'm just trying to emphasize
to you and I know you really know this
but I thought you might like to see it
empirically that there's a considerable
amount of variation in this state on a
lot of different Dimensions another one
is poverty New Hampshire is blessed by
having one of the lowest often the
lowest poverty rate of any US state but
that doesn't mean that there aren't
parts of New Hampshire where there's
significant amounts of poverty here we
look at the state as a whole at the
census tracks in the state and then
another closeup of Manchester so you
could see it in the Manchester area
where there's more poverty uh than in
many other parts of the state this is
children again poverty tend to be higher
among children although fortunately New
Hampshire's child poverty rate again is
one of the lowest if not the lowest in
the United States but that doesn't mean
there aren't places where there are poor
children in New Hampshire and you can
see that both at the state level and
then in the in the uh in the Manchester
area and finally this is poverty among
older adults older adults tend to have
lower poverty rates than other groups
and you can see that's true in New
Hampshire but again there are places
where there are poor older adults in the
state so again I'm just trying to I I
just want you to see how remarkably
diverse on many dimensions the state of
New Hampshire
is why do people move to New Hampshire
and why do they stay in New Hampshire
this is based on some of my most recent
research with one of my graduate
students and we asked a substantial
sample of people from New England or
from New Hampshire why they chose to
move to New Hampshire if they' moved
recently or why they like to stay in the
state if they've lived here for a long
time and again I I mentioned to you
before and I emphasized to you again how
important migration is to New Hampshire
again these are the most some of the
most recent data here's natural increase
again the state is has more deaths than
births so it's not growing from that
here's migration into the state both
immigration and domestic migration when
we ask people why do they move to New
Hampshire or why do they live in New
Hampshire here's what we found the
single largest reason both for the blue
people who are recent migrants to the
state who've come to New Hampshire in
the last 10 years and for people who
have lived in New Hampshire for 10 years
and more the most important reason for
staying in New Hampshire or moving to
New Hampshire is
family they care that carries great
weight with both of these groups the
natural environment the beauty the ities
the lakes and the mountains the Clean
Air of New Hampshire is the second most
important
factor uh for long-term residents of the
state and almost and uh also important
to recent migrants to the state quality
of life you know which is about
neighborhoods and relationships and the
little towns that they live in or the
interaction that they're involved with
are other measures that are very
important both to establish residents
and to recent migrants they do differ as
you would expect on employment
employment is a much more important
factor to recent migrants than it is to
people who've lived in the state for a
long time and again you when you think
about it one of the reasons people would
come to New Hampshire would be for a new
job or for uh other kinds of
activities taxes which I know is a big
issue in New Hampshire are mentioned by
some people but they're not nearly as
important as things like family art
lifestyle and culture the kind of rural
feel of New Hampshire the close
relationships is another and then people
answered about the general economy too
so when you're thinking about what
attracts people to New Hampshire or what
keeps people in New Hampshire these are
important factors and this we looked at
this both for people under 50 and older
50 and you can see the patterns are
quite similar it's f family that's
important employment is more important
especially to younger people which again
is what we would expect these are recent
migrants to the state these are people
who've lived here for a long
time same thing these are people moving
to or staying in New Hampshire with
college degrees or not college degrees
you can see the differential importance
of factors now again if anybody's
interested in this in more detail we
wrote a research piece on this that is
on the car SE website and if anybody
wants it you're certainly welcome to go
to the car SE website and download it or
you can send me a note and I'll be happy
to send it to you so I don't have time
to talk about them in detail today I
just wanted you to see uh so migration
as I've said is important to New
Hampshire's future when you think about
what's important for New Hampshire and
for making New Hampshire a good place to
live bear in mind there's a lot of focus
on attracting people to New Hampshire
and I think that's certainly relevant
but the other thing I would point out to
you is it's important to retain the
population that New Hampshire has and so
when you think about the kinds of
policies and factors that you might be
able to impact in your work recognize
that retaining population is important
just like attracting migrants sometimes
so much focuses on attraction that you
don't think as much about I'm not saying
you I'm saying demographers too don't
think about the people who stay they
only think about the people who leave
and the people who come and you could
see again how important
family and again when you think about
family think about things like good
quality K12
education uh access to playgrounds and
things like that preserving the natural
environment which is also important to a
lot of people and the quality of life
factors that we might be able to
contribute to uh and then of course
employment opportunities are important
as well so just to close because I know
I'm running out of time just some key
points population growth in New
Hampshire slowed compared to what it
used to be in the 80s and 90s but it's
picked up in the last few years and it
may well be I think probably this is the
result of the recession's impact finally
beginning to diminish only the
economists think that the recession
ended in 2010 certainly demographers
don't
there are now fewer births and deaths in
New Hampshire and covid is going to
exacerbate that so migration is going to
become even more important as I showed
you demographic change is uneven about
across the state some areas are growing
some aren't New Hampshire's population
is aging and diversity is growing from
the youngest to the oldest in the state
of New Hampshire so I think I'll stop
there I've got a couple other slides but
I think I'll stop there so that there's
time for questions thank you well thank
you Dr Johnson again
you had an excellent
presentation uh the first person with
questions is representative
Ames thank you um and just to Echo at
the beginning representative Major's
comment that was truly an excellent
presentation so thank you for that um so
I I really had two two-pronged question
one is
um about the data and particularly the
data on poverty and uh median family
income or household income whatever
you're using and your sources for that
and how good it is how how much we can
rely on it for example in uh school
funding formulas or other ways we have
Distributing state aid do we have good
enough data that uh identify population
by income level and then uh the other I
guess uh quite different question but
I'll put it in so you can just respond
is uh the uh schools the K to2
educational system that we have and its
strengths and weaknesses from Community
to community varies a great deal as you
know and uh whether you have information
on the degree to which uh uh people
considering coming to New Hampshire or
considering leaving New
Hampshire um are uh stirred to move in
One Direction or the other by the
equality of the local
school so first with reference to the
information on income and poverty this
comes from the Census bureau's American
Community survey which is an ongoing
survey done by the Census Bureau of
about four million households a year and
it it keeps rolling all the time and so
the data is as good as we have is it
does it give us a a good idea of what's
going on at the state level certainly at
the county level yes when you get down
to these individual tracks or smaller
places this is sample data so there are
errors I mean there is a sampling error
around any one of those measures the
data I presented to you and that I use
is five years of data so I don't rely on
single year data even though it
exists does it have the I mean if it
said that Manchester's median income was
87 ,
255 would I be confident that that's
exactly what it is no would I be
confident that it's between 95 and
80,000 and that that's one of the would
I yes I would be confident of that would
I be confident that the places
that the Census Bureau says have higher
incomes really do have higher incomes
and the places that the census buau has
low incomes really do have lower incomes
yes I would not I mean I wouldn't I
would be hesitant to use a formula that
relied on the absolute
number okay um so again those are the
some of those datas used to be asked in
the desial census the one that's done
every 10 years the census buau does not
ask those questions in the desial census
anymore so the data do not have as large
a representation as they would in the
census when it would have been asked
like 18% of the households rather than
about 4 % but it's continuous whereas
the decennial Census Data would only be
asked once every 10 years so there are
tradeoffs involved but it is it's the
best data that's available as what it
boils down to your other
question uh I don't have
data on migration decision making at
that small level of geography as a
school district or uh our data was I
mean we had a sample of around four
th000 from the whole state which is a
substantial sample but would not allow
us to make comments about what's
happening at individual Town levels for
example we do in the one thing about
this survey that's different than ones
that are usually used is we actually ask
the people for the top three reasons why
they chose to live in New Hampshire or
come to New Hampshire they told us in
their own words this wasn't a check the
little box next to educ ation or income
uh and then we had to translate all of
those I think it was 8,000 responses
into category so that we could show the
summary data but my point is that we let
them answer in their own words and
education was certainly something that
was mentioned by some people so uh again
we're pretty pleased with the data this
is for one set we did it for two
different periods one during the Great
Recession one after the patterns are
almost identical between the two and
again if you want more detail I'd be
happy to to send you the question I mean
to send you the study we did and you can
read it for
yourself thank you so much
representative Barney
Brony thank you Dr Johnson good
presentation uh the first slide that you
showed you showed the net outflow and
net inflow for all the New England
states uh um in Connecticut was not
doing very well the last four years uh
that kind of correlates with three new
people that moved into my town that I
talked to when I was campaigning this
year who said they escaped
Connecticut and their their main reasons
was what tax tax policies in Connecticut
are out of
control we know from ways and means when
we talk about casinos for instance that
casino revenues were off and the state
in of Connecticut was looking for other
places to to go and obviously they've
been increasing uh taxes and other
things they characterize Connecticut is
in a death spiral because large
corporations are moving out uh they just
can't take it anymore one of my
constituents had 500 a business of 500
people that he he actually he and his
sun in business they moved they moved to
to Texas and he moved and retired up
here um so I guess what I'm getting at
is that it seems like there's a
correlation even though your what you
show in the last slide didn't indicate
it but it seems like there's a
correlation between tax policy and
migration in and out of a state um if I
maybe this is more of a comment I guess
but you know it would seem interesting
if we want to focus on a state to look
at maybe Connecticut maybe there's an
example there of a state that's policies
are counter to increasing flow into the
state just from my an total uh
conversations that I've
had well I appreciate that we certainly
got some comments in the in the survey
about people moving to New Hampshire
because of taxes um I have not done
in-depth research on this so I really
can't address the issue of the
relationship between tax policy and
migration there I would say to you that
there that one of the things we learned
from that survey and from other research
we've done is people don't move for a
single reason there's usually multiple
reasons that underly people's decision
either to move or to stay in a given
place
so than
you representative
janigan thank you Mr chairman um good
presentation Dr Johnson um my question
centers around the fact that uh the
birth rate in New Hampshire is so low is
that how does that compare with with
other states I don't know if you
mentioned that or I missed but is that
are we much lower than than other states
is there a concern that New Hampshire
for some reason has a very low birth
rate um so there are at least three
factors that go into the birth
rate uh one
is the number of women of childbearing
age so that affects how many births
there are and indirectly affects the
birth rate depending on how it's
measured but um
so New Hampshire has a relatively small
proportion of women of childbearing age
because its population is
older the birth rates in New Hampshire
are relatively low compared to other
states but not dramatically lower than
in other states New Hampshire's
population as I showed you is largely
non-hispanic white although that is
changing the non-hispanic white
population generally tends to have lower
birth rates than other age groups
although that's less true in New
Hampshire because the um the largest
minority group in New Hampshire is
Hispanics but they don't tend to be
immigrants that have come directly from
Mexico or other places the next largest
immigrant group in New Hampshire are
Asians Asian fertility rates especially
among well educated Asians tend to be
lower than they do among even
non-hispanic whites so it's partially
the mix the population in New Hampshire
the racial and ethnic mix that is a
factor as well and then the birth rates
are affected by uh lots of other kinds
of factors like we expect Co is going to
have a big effect and I as I said to you
we're demographers are mostly expecting
the birth rates to go down just like the
guy who just mentioned anot anecdotal
Trends I've had three people in the last
day tell me that they're going to have a
child in the next six or eight months so
so I hope I'm I'm happy for them but I
suspect that's not going to be the
generalized Trend so anyway I mean
that's just an as side if you want to
know more about fertility I could I have
a whole class on it that I'm going to
teach in a couple weeks you're you're
certainly invited to come and talk to
us I'm not being factious I just yes New
Hampshire does tend to have a relatively
low birth rate it has a lot of it has a
relatively small proportion of its
population of childbearing age and its
racial ethnic mix would also tend to
cause the birth rate to be lower in the
state okay thank you do Dr Johnson when
do you anticipate having the 2020 census
information and the result of the
pandemic that you can roll into your
presentation right
so the Census
Bureau generally would have released the
first of the Census Data the
reapportionment file by December 31st of
2020 so it should have already been
released but because of the
pandemic um everything in the census has
been slowed down the expectation is that
that first number which will only tell
you the state's
population and the number of people over
the age of 18 is supposed to now be
released probably in late
March probably in March is the current
expectation the more detailed data about
what's going on in different parts of
New Hampshire and among different age
groups in New Hampshire those data will
be released over time over the next year
and so probably if you invite me back to
talk to you again in a year we'll have
be able to incorporate a lot of the 2020
Census Data into that conversation we
probably will be doing that
okay I don't see any other questions and
again we thank you Dr Johnson those nor
nor Norm yes Senator dandre was trying
to get your attention before
Oh not pushing the button to rise okay
Senator D oh thank you thank you
do Mr Johnson really appreciate your
presentation uh a few years ago I I I
was I was working uh doing a job for the
University and and I did a a study that
resembles some of the work that you did
obviously but my question is the
southern the Southern Tier of New
Hampshire what I found in my study was
it really had a Massachusetts
orientation that they lived lived in New
Hampshire but from a social standpoint
they did their social uh activities in
in in Massachusetts and many of them
worked in Massachusetts but lived in New
Hampshire and and that's what drove that
income up uh so high is that still the
case it it is a case that a substantial
portion of the population that that
lives in the southern part of New
Hampshire uh does commute to work in in
Massachusetts in fact um Rockingham and
Stratford counties are actually
considered to be part of the Boston
metropolitan area so and that that
decision on how to classify those
counties depends significantly on
commuting data and so that reflects the
the kind of thing that you're seeing uh
in your in the research you did as
well thank thank
you does anybody else have any questions
I don't see any hands
raised all right again we want to thank
you Dr Johnson and and thank all the
participants for anticipating today
tomorrow we start again at 9 o' and
we're going to have uh Jeffrey Schultz
CFA director who's going to discuss the
regional and National economy 10 o'cl
Phil Sutton from a senior policy analyst
New Hampshire fiscal po policy Institute
discuss State economic conditions and
economic
forecast 11:00 Dave J from New Hampshire
business and industry Association
discussing current business challenges
and prediction for the year to come and
he'll have with him representatives from
small and large
businesses and then at 1:00 Ben Frost
managing director of New Hampshire
housing Financial Authority discussed
the state's housing market and housing
challenges and then at 1:30 Patricia
Tilly deputy director division of Public
Health Services Department of Health and
Human Services discussing pandemic
conditions
in the state and status of the vaccine
distribution so until then uh we'll see
you at nine o'clock tomorrow morning
great no thank you so much for all of
your hard work of putting this together
I think it's terrific and uh
representative Ames I I admire your
questioning you're one of my favorites
no question no question in my mind
you're a top you're a top man thank
you represent a major yes you do know
that there's an inauguration starting at
noon
tomorrow
okay
the are you going to be
missing I think I think I will have to
be missing